let's see
okay
thank you so much
enjoy your day
good morning
all right
the circuit court of fairfax county is
now in session young penny asked ronnie
president
good morning
all right do we have any preliminary
matters before the journey just one
exhibit
oh perfect which exhibit
1458
1458.
all right with redactions
all right
that's already been entered in evidence
we'll just
take a copy of it
anything else we have the um thumb drive
with the original the uh with the
knife pictures on it for me knight two
and i three great thank you
all right
i'll take any energy
all right anything further
all right we're ready for the jury
so
um
good morning ladies and gentlemen you
can have a seat
all right cross examination
morning mr depp morning mr roddenberg
yes two days ago when you first took the
stand you discussed your upbringing and
some of the abuse that you suffered at
the hands of your mother do you remember
that
yes i do
and you testified how she abused you
physically right
yes sir throwing things at you
hitting you
yeah there was quite a
yeah very various forms of
physical abuse and she abused you
verbally by insulting you and your
siblings right
yes you do and you testify that
sometimes that that verbal abuse that
emotional abuse was worse than the
beatings right do you remember that
as a child it um
it um
has more of an opportunity to plant
itself in your head
sure yes
so you'd agree that abuse can take many
forms it can be physical can be verbal
can be emotional right indeed
and you you testified that your dad
wasn't abusive but that
you saw him punch walls
when he was in an argument with your
mother sometimes right
excuse me
um i i
i witnessed my father
the only um
reaction that would be called a physical
reaction from
the abuse he was
very stoically taking
from my mother
um i saw him
maybe twice three times
punch a
wall once as i said once he punched the
corner of the wall and i watched his
hand uh hints a hand basically you
shatter
right
mr depp your
walls weren't the only thing that your
father punched were they in fact
once he punched you in the face and
knocked you down didn't he
um
[Music]
he
yes when i was um
15
years old this was
this was just before i'd
dropped out of high school
one morning yes
in my mind i was done with school
so
he had asked me to
i believe it was something it was very
he asked me to
take the dog for a walk or something
or take out the garbage something menial
something strange and uh
i just said
no
and he
and he gave me
he just gave me a quick shot
um
pretty hefty
and
yeah
it rattled my head right on the cage you
know
sweet birds and stuff sure so the jury
hadn't heard about that before when he
punched you in the face that actually
knocked you to the ground
and then when you got up you were all
too happy to take care of what he wanted
you to take care of right i was excited
to take care of it right and yesterday
um i believe that you testified why
would you hit someone to make them agree
with you it doesn't work you gave that
testimony yesterday didn't you
yes
now you try to conduct yourself as a
gentleman right
yes sir
and you think that you live up to the
standards of a southern gentleman
right
um
[Music]
that was essentially
you know when you have deep deep roots
in the south and kentucky and such
um
it's not just your
your parents your
father your mother it's your
grandparents it's your uncles it's your
aunts it's this it's that it's a
yes raised to be the southern gentleman
that is to say
when chivalry was still alive and
allowed
right and you think you live up to the
standards of a southern gentleman
correct
i believe i do i certainly
have done my best all my life
paul bettany is a good friend that
you've done drugs with right
that's a strange question um paul
bettany is a good friend
yes you've done drugs with him yes i
have cocaine
right oh cocaine yes alcohol
alcohol yes pills including xanax and
adderall right
um
that i'm not too sure
okay um
where's he going
your honor may we approach i just want
to discuss one thing with you okay miss
myers
thank you
mr depp you you remember giving
testimony in
um the trial in the uk correct
yes
and you gave that testimony under oath
right
yes
um
you were you were
you gave quite a bit of testimony in
that trial right
i wouldn't be able to
judge that myself
it felt like a lot okay well let's take
a look at some of it if you can turn to
page 45 please in front of you
it's it's page
12 of the document there's
four transcript pages of the document
yes sir
yes
sir um
club of the document you say yes in the
lower left corner there's a page 45 do
you see that
yes i do okay
um
and you see that uh on on the bottom of
that page
um there's a discussion of of paul
bettany and and the things
drugs that you did together and there
was a question the question is any sort
of pills
and your answer is yes there could have
been xanax or if he needed if he asked
for xanax or adderall whatever i would
of course give it to him
question so you would supply paul
bettany with whatever medication or
control drugs he asked for is that right
answer if he was feeling anxious or if
he was feeling unpleasant i would give
him what he asked for
question would you give him a xanax
answer
yes
did i read that right you certainly did
yesterday and you shared
the two of you shared an enjoyment of
controlled drugs or alcohol at that time
right
the two of us were making a film
together
um with respect sir that wasn't my
question my question was the two of you
shared an enjoyment of controlled drugs
and alcohol at that time yes or no
at times yes and
miss heard was quite adamant that you
didn't drink anymore and that you should
stop using recreational drugs right
oh yes and she didn't like it when you
were high on drugs or drunk on alcohol
right
she didn't like it when it was her
perception that i was high on drugs her
perception's quite different than the
truth
and that's that's what we're after is
the truth let's turn to can you pull up
exhibit 178 please michelle
is that
defendants 178 or yes your honor okay
i'm sorry i just want to make sure
mr depp um objected in your honor
can we approach
mr depp this
this is a text message exchange that you
had with paul
bettany on june 11 2013 correct yes
correct
you're on our permission to uh move for
admission of
redacted defendants exhibit 178. and
permission to publish please
we
based off of your honors ruling all
right that's fine 178 with redactions
michelle could you please
blow up the first text at the top
in this text
mr depp
you text mr bettany let's burn amber
three excellent exclamation points right
you see that i do see that
and
at this time
june 11 2013 amber is your girlfriend or
perhaps even your fiance at this point
correct
girlfriend yeah for sure and and you
didn't stop
when you said let's burn amber
because the the next text down you can
move down and blow up the next text
please michelle
you say
let's drown her before we burn her three
exclamation points did i read that right
uh
yes it's referenced
prior too
you didn't stop and you said let's drown
her before we burn her
after that you made another comment and
i'd like to apologize to the court and
to the jury for some of the language
that i'm gonna have to use today but
unfortunately
um
you're gonna see a lot of documents with
language like this
after you said let's drown her before we
burn her mr depp you said i will [ __ ]
her burnt corpse afterwards to make sure
she is dead
that's what you said that you would do
after you burned her and after you
drowned her did i read that right
you certainly did yes and you wrote that
about the woman who would later become
your wife
yes i do can you pull up exhibit 245
please
your honor there's been
no objection to this exhibit and so i'd
move for its admission and ask for
permission to publish to the jury give
them a moment
your honor we have no objection to the
portions that have mr depp's text
messages but at the bottom portion there
is some from his daughter that we would
ask be redacted
and your honor
that's okay but there's no there was no
objection to this on the
exhibit list but they don't appear to be
relevant which
that's fine we're happy to redact those
all right so 245 in evidence with the
redactions yes yes your honor okay
thank you
mr depp um
this uh the top
text message we're gonna focus on a
couple of these but the top text message
is a text from you to paul bettany
on may 30th 2014 correct i need to
scroll over michelle
may 30th 2014. yes
and and you recall that
you testified yesterday about the flight
that you took from boston to los angeles
on may 24th 2014 right yes remember that
okay
and you testified yesterday that you
didn't
have any drinks before that flight or
maybe you had a glass of champagne or
something remember giving that testimony
he said believe i said i had a
glass of champagne on the
on the plane right
so in this text if you could blow up
michelle please that top
text
on may 30th
2014
you texted
mr bettany
just a little bit smaller
you texted mr betany i'm gonna properly
stop the booze thing darling
drank all night before i picked amber up
to fly to la this past sunday ugly mate
no food for days
powders
half a bottle of whiskey
a thousand red bull and vodkas
pills
two bottles of champers on plane and
what do you get
an angry aggro engine in a [ __ ]
blackout
screaming obscenities and insulting any
[ __ ] who got near
i'm done
i'm admittedly too [ __ ] in the head to
spray my rage
at the one i love
read that again i'm admittedly too
[ __ ] in the head
to spray my rage at the one i love
for little reason as well i'm too old to
be that guy
but pills are fine
did i read that right yes she did
and when you said pills are fine this
was when you were just starting
treatment with dr kipper to try to get
off of the pills that you testified
about yesterday right
this is when i was still on the uh
oxycodone it was before the um
detox on the island yes right and you
testify that when you were in boston
filming black mass where which you flew
from from boston to l.a that you would
just retain dr kipper to help you try to
combat that pill problem right yes okay
could you go two texts down please
michelle
and this is a text that you sent
on
june 8 2014 just scroll over
to
patty smith
you see that yes i do okay and in this
text i i i won't read all of it
but you say this
my daughter i'm to just read the first
paragraph my darling patty lee
i miss you and worship you and there is
nothing wrong between us
never ever could that happen
i've just been so beyond busy with film
here in boston and then back to la for
kitties
when i was in nyc they were brief visits
and [ __ ] and charged by horrific
fights with amber
i [ __ ] up and drank and got shitty
was so disappointed in myself
actually almost walked to your place at
about 3 30 a.m the last time i was there
unable to stop
he tears
did i read that right you did
michelle can you please take that down
and let's pull up
exhibit 325
please
mr depp is this a text message exchange
that you had with miss heard
on december 18 2014.
i see that
your honor i would um
move for admission of this exhibit and
ask for permission to publish all right
any objection
yeah i have a look at the um of course
your honor maybe approach real quick
okay sure
and michelle if you could just scroll
down as
so
the court
and mr depp's counsel and mr depp can
see it all
is that all of it
oh sorry your honor we have no objection
with the on to the unredacted version
okay so
this version that we're seeing right now
correct make sure yes okay all right
325.
hold on excuse me sorry i just want to
make clear we haven't seen the other
pages but this page we have no
exceptions this is the only page
i believe this is the only page to the
document your honor right 325 is only
one page just one page okay thank you
no redactions
other than
identifiers but yes you can do this one
and
michelle if you can blow up the large
text at the top of the page
mr depp on december 18 2014
you sent this text
to
miss heard
and i'm going to read it
and it says it's a way
i've let it go
went too far
we slash i tend to do that
i always regret it when i jump or worse
when you jump
i don't want to be conditioned to
continue that behavior
therefore i'll put in heavy work with
shrank
i'm sorry for being less for your
disappointment in me
for my behavior
i'm a [ __ ] savage
gotta lose that
gonna lose that
the devil is all around right
i wish i were able to bring even just a
glimmer of a smile to the pretty face of
my most gorgeous of dreams and darkest
nightmares
i love you far too much for you and i to
be these heinous slinging insults like
we do slash did
it is not anything that i am
particularly proud of to have
participated in
and i regret giving it life because
[ __ ] how when we fight little
girl how do we end up on the very edge
of the precipice and why
wish i knew
god damn
and know that you are right
i am well aware that i should have been
bigger than the moment
and that it will never again manifest in
negative experiences it can be done
what a killer concept to visualize wish
you were in this lunatic's proximity be
careful out there i adore you
did i read that right you did
you can take that down michelle
if you could please pull up exhibit 153
so
okay
in your honor we have a redacted version
of this but we'll put up the fully
unredacted um
right now all right just give counsel a
moment of course
your honor this has phone numbers in it
so i know yeah i know we understood just
so you can see it first okay
okay can i have the photo you don't take
pictures of what's on your screen
okay i'm just making sure
thank you
you your honor
mr depp um
i'd like to to to turn your attention to
the top three text messages on this page
these are text messages that you sent on
january 17th 2013. see that
i'm sure i'm just reading the
page
right and the way these text messages
are produced sometimes there's big date
skips and they're they're kind of
jumbled in so they're not all on the
same chain so of course what i'm what
i'm asking you about is just the top
three certainly
and
those are texts that you wrote on
january 17 2013 correct
yes
you're on our permission to publish just
those top three texts with identifiers
and the others redacted
and and move for admission of that
redacted exhibit
um as long as it's not this version
that's fine
we'll put it we'll put up on the screen
what i propose to uh admit as an example
let me see what you're gonna put up on
this okay first
we have no objection to this version
okay
michelle can you blow up the text boxes
please
on january 17 2013 mr depp
you texted
the following
for the idiot cow
three exclamation points next text
will do
i'll smack the ugly [ __ ] around before i
let her in don't worry
apologies again to the court and the
jury for this language
and then you close by saying did that
worthless hooker arrive did i read that
right
you did so
you can take that down please
we talked a little bit about the term
monster yesterday correct
yes i've heard that word quite a lot
yeah and you you testified yesterday
that you used that term to placate amber
right
and i believe that you testified that it
was the word that she clung to to
describe what was in her mind not yours
i wrote down what you said you remember
giving that testimony
the monster
more than anything was
miss heard's
way of referencing
whether i was
whether she perceived that i was on
substances or taking substances so the
word monster became
it represented for her
the
consumption of of
alcohol or any other substances
whether it was actually happening or not
her perception
and so monster became
her
click word right if you will but but
actually the term monster to describe
yourself came from you
well initially misheard
i believe she started out with demons
she started out
saying that i had demons
and then when monster
was put into
a conversation which again uh my my
i have a
particular
way of using
uh words vocabulary uh in my
uh in my vernacular
so
monster
uh
was something that
if it which she's
stuck with tried and true i mean she
just stayed with that right but you have
to
came from you unless you wanted to argue
the term came from you didn't it
uh it's very probable
possible it's probable that i that i
might have used that that work certainly
right and and in 2012 in fact um elton
john was one of your
friends who was trying to help you get
sober correct
yes sir
and
you
you sent him a message in 2012 where you
thanked him for his help and you said
quote
i would have been swallowed up by the
monster were it not for you that is a
simple fact
isn't that true yes
again the monster referring to
alcohol and and substances
correct and you didn't send that message
to miss heard you sent that to elton
john
i would have been swallowed up by the
monster were it not for you
um correct elgin elton uh
can you pull up each other
was a dear friend who
um
has been um
sober for
i don't 40 years 30 years so he was um
we'd had discussions and he wanted to me
to
get
clean sober
so he actually elton actually sent
a
fellow called charlie dunnett who'd
worked with elton for years and years
listen i appreciate that my only
question was just to confirm that you
had sent that message to ellen john
nothing else thank you so i'll just go
okay i'll just stop
thank you i appreciate it i want to be
respectful of the fourth time the jury's
time
i i just said i want to be respectful of
the court's time and the jury's time and
i trust that you do too so
i don't feel like i'm wasting anyone's
time sir could you pull up exhibit 408
please
mr depp i'd like to to turn your
attention to the bottom text on this
page
um
and
can you confirm that this is a text
message that you
sent on april 9 2015
while you were
married to amber
to
your sister do you see that
the the last
the
the last text on the one on the bottom
yes i see that yes
um your honor a move for admission of
408 with
all the identifiers redacted and
everything except the last text redacted
just the last one yes your honor one
text
um we object your honor we uh we could
approach just very quickly
just the one i had and the one above it
okay
and mr depp um
to clarify is cis in those texts is that
is that your sister um or it could be
amber's sister too right
sis i was referring to whitney whitney
okay so amber's sister okay amber
christian
your honor with those redactions i'd ask
for permission or move to admit exhibit
408 no
no objection yes all right 408 with
redactions
mr depp um on
april 9th
2015 yes
while you were married to miss heard
you texted
someone named sis which maybe her sister
you testified yes
you said i'm all right
i
dot dot dot though
i never ever
want to lay eyes on that filthy [ __ ]
amber a
most embarrassing
did i read that right
yes you did and and when you called
amber that filthy [ __ ] she was your
wife at the time correct
yes sir let's pull up exhibit 427
unredacted please
mr depp i would like to um
i'd like to direct your attention
okay is there another
let's see
i'd like to direct your attention to the
fourth text up from the bottom
chat number one six one six
you see that
yes i do
um
and that's a text message exchange
between you and jerry judge
on april 26 2015 just a couple of weeks
after
you referred to to amber as a filthy
[ __ ]
do you see that yes it is okay your
honor permission to
um and move for admission of this
exhibit with the um the two text
exchanges um
in that chat between him and jerry judge
all right well why don't you show me
what it would look like redacted
okay can we do that okay sure
it's just those two michelle
so
all right
any objection to 427
no objections with reductions okay 427
with redactions thank you your honor
if you can just blow the text text up
michelle of both of those
mr depp on april 26 2015 jerry judge
and
jerry judge is your former security guy
who passed away a couple years ago right
that's great
um
and he writes you and says hi boss just
wanted to say if you and amber need
anything just let me know i will be
there in 20 minutes
johnny it is lovely to see how you and
amber are so happy the other day
watching the two of you sitting on the
bench by the sea was fantastic the two
of you need happiness and it is really
great to see that love to you and amber
xoxo jerry i read that right
you did
and beneath that you texted him back and
you said
thank you my dear jerry
very very kind mate
we've been perfect
all i had to do was send the monster
away and lock him up
we've been happier than ever
all caps
love you brother
jd
did i read that right you did soon
michelle could you please pull up
exhibit 445
defendants
and in the text that we just saw
when you were used the word monster that
misheard wasn't on that text message was
she
no that was between jerry and myself
thank you
mr depp i'd like to direct your
attention in this message to the second
text down
which is a text from you
to dr kipper dr david kipper
on june 28 2015. okay is that right
um
yes 26 28 215 yes
your honor um a move for the admission
of a redacted exhibit with that simply
that text we're happy to redact the rest
of it set text 139 or 137 137 your honor
i'm sorry seven
uh no objection with the proper
redactions get those redactions before
we publish or did you want to publish
yes
um we'll just we'll make the redactions
right now and then
publish that okay thank
you all right 440
445 as redacted yes your honor all right
in evidence thank you
and you sent this text on june 28 2015
and it said you can blow up the text
michelle please
thank you my darling kipper
all those technical abbreviations left
me flummoxed and in the dark
soon soon i must see you and just hang
out
my deformed finger and i have no friends
by the way
amber and i have been absolutely perfect
for three [ __ ] months solid
i've locked my monster child away in a
cage deep within and it has [ __ ]
worked
we're goddamn best friends now amazing
big luck big love to you my brother jd
did i read that right
yes you did and amber wasn't on that
text when you told dr kipper that you
locked your monster child away in a cage
deep within was she
no
can we pull up
exhibit 435 please unredacted
it's just the bottom text that i'm going
to direct your attention to mr depp this
is a text that you sent
to stephen deuters on may 14 2015 right
the last one yep
may 14th and steven deuters is your
personal assistant or was your personal
assistant at the time you were
with miss heard right yes he's an online
partner and okay
now he's the the president of the
european um
branch of infinitum nile right into yes
okay
move for admission of a redacted version
of this document with just the bottom
text your honor
no objection all right if you just
redacted just to the bottom text
thank you judge
all right 435 and evidence has rejected
and on may 14th
2015. you blow out that text michelle
please
you texted mr deuters
need to discuss the news helicopters
hovering outside the house this morning
i'm ready to shoot a [ __ ]
but don't worry
the monster is not involved
correct that's i see that yes and miss
heard wasn't on that text was she
no
let's pull up exhibit 196 please
this on page two please
are we on are we on page two
yeah so it's mr depp i'd like to direct
your attention to
um line 24 you can see in that left hand
column there
and this is a text message from you to
stephen duders your your personal
assistant at the time
on october 31st 2013
correct
yes sir
permission to publish or move for
admission your honor of this just this
page of the exhibit with just that text
uh with the phone numbers redacted we
have no objections we could do those
redactions so just be page two
of exhibit 196. yes you're on it are you
ever going to
enter any other pages of this exhibit
into evidence i'd like to reserve the
right to then we'll call it 1996a okay
thank you that makes it easier for the
record all right thank you okay
permission to publish your own all right
196a in evidence as rejected
and in this text message from you to mr
deuters
on october 31st
2013
you write
thanks she thinks that my peruvian
period has made me a monster
and that i am ruining the relationship
you see that
yes i do sir the peruvian period is a
reference to cocaine is it not yes it is
i'm sorry you said yes it is
yes it is yeah okay let's go to exhibit
293 please
mr depp i'd like to direct your
attention to the bottom
uh text which is a text from you to an
unknown number
on october 4th
2014.
do you see that
the last one yes you said yes i see that
yes sir
your honor i'd move uh for the admission
of modified exhibit 293
with um just that
redacted
version
and we may use other parts of it so i'd
ask it to be 293
a or one
okay we can make it a let's okay keep
consistent
i forgot what you'd said no objection
all right 293 a we'll get the redactions
done
all right 293
maybe
there we go
all right
back to 93 a in evidence with redactions
thank you your honor
and in this text message on october 4th
2014 you text
someone it's unclear who
you say i'm going to quite gracefully
glide into a massage of my broken back
and neck
i shall exit in one hour a monster
shall we each swallow
an e each
parenthesis or perhaps it's mdma at
around 8 pm
and go to dinner with a few of my we
team
at a wonderful peruvian spot
let us enjoy this night my brother let
us reward ourselves for the hard work
and misery of the heat that we push
ourselves to conquer every goddamn day
the
shatter i read that right
you did and and
e here that's a reference to x to c
correct it is
you take that down michelle please
you would agree that you found drugs and
alcohol at an early stage in your life
right
absolutely yes i did and you testified a
couple days ago that you'd done just
about every kind of drug there was by
age
13 or 14 right 15 15.
and you've
um
you found that drugs are the only way to
numb your pain
right
they've always been um a medicine from
yes a numbing agent and you said
yesterday that in fact i i think you
said you take drugs to numb the demons
right
i don't know that i said to numb the
demons but i
have well
if i did say demons it's
it is to numb
the
residual
um
pain that i carry from
my
youth
right
and um one of one of your good friends
that you've taken drugs with before is
marilyn manson right
um
[Music]
yes we've taken uh
uh we've drank
together uh
we've
we've uh we've had cocaine together
maybe a couple of times
um pills right
with marilyn manson um
i once gave
marilyn manson a pill
so that he would
stop talking so much
sorry all right
i get it
you employ you employ
a lot of people that work for you right
i employ a lot of people you employ a
lot of people that serve various roles
in your life right
yes there's they're they're yes and and
and at least some of those people will
do anything you ask including some of
them supplying controlled drugs to you
correct
i would not characterize those people as
doing anything i want or anything i said
they're not
the yes men that you'd like them to be
can you turn uh pick up your
your testimony from the uk trial
and turn to page
48 which is page 13 of the document
please yes
um
oh yes sorry
yes i've got it you got it okay
and if you could please take a look at
um
page 48
line 15
20 line 15.
you just testified that they're not yes
men right
that was the testimony you just gave
correct
yes okay on page 48 line 15 um of your
testimony in the uk you were asked the
question they are people who will do
what you ask they will do anything you
ask including some of them supplying
drugs to you controlled drugs to you
your answer was there are people who
work for me
work with me who yes in the past have
been asked to provide whatever i have
felt was necessary at the time
question well putting it bluntly if you
wanted illegal drugs controlled drugs
and you asked one of your staff and i'm
not going to name anybody particularly
right now that member of staff would
provide you with those drugs if he could
answer at times yes
question despite the fact that it was
illegal
answer yes
did i read that right you did
can we pull up exhibit 1085 please
you've seen this picture before mr depp
right
yes i have yes
um
and this is a picture that was taken in
miss herd's um
former house or apartment on orange
avenue after you two began dating
correct
yes sir and it's so it's quite a
composition
composition of the photograph is very
interesting i i i think that's something
we can agree on um
you're on a move for admission of
exhibit 1085 and ask for permission no
objection you're all right 1085 publish
in another
and this picture um
you recall mr jeff was taken in in or
around march of 2013
after you had fallen off the wagon right
oh i'm sure what date march of 2013 i
believe 23rd is that bring a bell
um
if
march 23rd
um i had
uh
fallen off the wagon from when we were
when i was doing lone ranger when mr was
with me when i was uh sober okay um but
that was those the whiskey
um that's on the table was
that was an average
every day i would come home to her place
and there would be a glass of whiskey
waiting for me
and and you would sometimes drink
whiskey in the mornings too right
during this time period um
i i
i you know i mean
isn't happy hour anytime
and
that cocaine that those white lines
those are coca that's cocaine right
i will assume yeah and that's that's
your cocaine that you kept in that box
that says property of jd with the skull
and crossbones isn't it well the
beautiful composition of the photograph
would suggest that certainly yeah
you don't dispute that
i i don't see me in it no but you don't
dispute that that you carried cocaine in
that box that said property of jd that
was a special box that you carried
cocaine in wasn't it
the box was a gift from someone i can't
say that i carried cocaine in it now you
you can't say that you carried cocaine
in that box
no but it looks like it would fit some
cocaine
cocaine is
i would
in my experience normally
uh
given in plastic bags when you put it in
a box like that
um chances are very good you'll leave a
trail of
a long line of cocaine behind you okay
walking down the street so why don't you
go ahead and pull up your uk testimony
please
let's look at page 202.
yeah you're going by those things
pardon me it's page nine of the document
once
um
uh
i'm having trouble finding two are you
saying paige
no that's my fault it's day two so i owe
you another transcript i'm sorry my
apologies
oh
we're moving into another day now
thank you you're on our permission to
approach okay yes sir
thank you
thank you
so this and i apologize for that mr depp
um this is uh page 9 of the document
page 202 of the transcript this was day
two of your testimony in the uk
uh yes i see it page 202
yep
and
on that uh on page 202
um
you were asked the question we'll have
to work out what that was at a later
stage can you see in the front that
there is a little box about two inches
by two inches if we compare it to the
size of the credit cards
answer yes
property of jd with skull and crossbones
on it
yes i do
that i suggest is this is a question
that i suggest is your cocaine box that
is where you would keep your cocaine a
special box that you had
answer
i do remember the box
question do you remember it now
answer yes i did not remember the
property of jd
yes that is a box
it was carrying cocaine in it i would
say i probably was then
you see that
did i read that right yes you did
and on the morning that this picture was
taken
you were this was during the filming of
a documentary about keith richards you
remember that
um
yeah sure this picture was taken while
you were filming a documentary about
keith richards correct uh
i'm sorry the date again on this do you
remember that i believe i believe it's
march 2013. you could you should know
better than i assumed
okay and you see there's a keith
richards cd it looks like above that
cosmetic case perfectly pledged yes yeah
and you had an argument that morning in
which you accused amber of cheating on
you do you remember that um i believe
amber had an argument with me
and you were using cocaine and drinking
whiskey that morning and as a result of
that argument you were late to the set
of that documentary correct
um in fact that was not late to the
documentary uh well i was late but um i
had called
uh
my crew
because it was a day of
uh filming performance with between it
was keith richards
tom waits and some other
very
talented musicians
the only thing that needed to be done in
terms of performance was capture the
performance so
my
i wasn't
needed on the set so i could come in any
time i wanted okay you just said that
you were late though correct oh i was
just talking about it yes yes all right
and and due to the argument of course
sure um
i'd like to shift gears a little bit
now
well actually let's let's not
michelle could you please pull up
exhibit 152.
uh
mr depp these are our various
um
texts that you sent and received to
various people
um
in
2012. do you see that
yes seems to go from july to september
right right
and
um we'll take them kind of piece by
piece i guess um i guess the first thing
i'd like to do um
is take a look at uh
exhibits or i'm sorry the entries 1628
so that's
about halfway down the page it's a text
exchange a text from you
uh to stephen deuters your personal
assistant at the time
and then a text from him back to you
objection you're honored
uh
um
with redactions and evidence
thank you your honor appreciate your
patience
mr depp um we're going to take a look at
two two text messages here the or three
text messages um on august 4th 2012 you
exchanged text messages with stephen
deuters one from you to him and one from
him to you do you see that midway
through the page
yes
and michelle can you blow those up
please
in those text messages you
write to mr duders your personal
assistant
yay where is the little baggie you built
in la
and he says
special baggie i gave you can in 1480
kitchen
not sure where it went after that
thought i heard you say something along
the lines of i know what to do with it
exclamation point did i read that right
you did too all right can you scroll
down to the text on the bottom please
this is a text um
mr depp uh where you say i use marijuana
a lot
three exclamation points i take pot
i read that right correct yes you did
and and this is a text that you sent on
september 11 2012 to just scroll over to
the left michelle this is a text that
you sent to brian warner brian warner's
marilyn manson right that's great okay
let's pull up exhibit 145 please
[Music]
uh mr depp this is a series of text
messages um from you to and from various
people in 2012 right
yes sir
and your honor that the
text messages that i'd like to
ask the witness about are the first two
um
and then the um
or just those first two
all right we have no objection to the
emission with proper reductions okay you
could reject just those first two
and then move forward the admission of
that document that's redacted sure as
soon as we get redacted
nice michelle
that's fine no objection all right 145
and evidence as rejected thank you your
honor
so this text exchange mr depp between
you and marilyn manson on
september 11 2012
you text him
the pill and the plant stuff keep me
calm and detached
and he texts you back i have lots of
reefers
many reefers
and cookies
which are weird but pot is funny
backwards gateway drug do you see that i
do so did i read that right you did
you can take that down michelle please
and if you could please pull up
defendants exhibit 10 8 sorry 1 1089
1089
okay
mr depp i'd like to ask you about this
photo um this is a photo of
four
pretty huge bags of marijuana correct
yes sir that is a lot of marijuana a lot
of marijuana um and the coffee cup
that's right next to that that's that's
a coffee cup for your your company
infinitum nile right that's correct and
the the furniture this is taken in one
of your residences
uh it's taken in the studio the
recording studio in the recording studio
okay
um
you're on a move for the admission of
exhibit 1089 defendants exhibit 1089 and
permission to publish no objection 89
evidence
so this this picture of these four giant
bags of a pot at least four
um
was taken in your recording studio is
that right
yes okay you can you can take that down
michelle
are you at a good break point mr
rottenborn just sure i would break would
be fine okay all right thank you let's
go ahead and take our morning recess at
15 minutes uh so just don't talk to
anybody don't do the outside research
okay thank you ladies and gentlemen you
can be
released
so
all right
just we'll come back let's make 11 33
okay
all right thank you thank you
are you ready for the jury yes okay
um
uh
all right
be seated
next your next question
mr depp um
contrary to what maybe we've heard the
jury's heard earlier in this trial
you became aware many times over the
course of your life about your sister
christy's concerns about your drug
consumption correct
over many times in my life yes
i think you'd have to ask her that i'm
not i'm not aware that she was concerned
for the
period of my life
well in fact your sister's had a number
of worries about your drug consumption
over many many years since your youth
that you've become aware of correct
um
in in my youth
since your
since my youth my
sister has not been
um
necessarily privy to
[Music]
every single
let's say move that i've made whether it
be
where you'd like me to go with the
drug
dependency or whatever
um she has been a concerned sister in
every way
that even having to do with uh
relationships that i was in that she was
quite worried about
right right and i wasn't asking about
relationships what i was asking is just
let's do it this way given your
testimony let's let's turn to uh day two
of the uk trial the transcript that's in
front of you please
day two
so where would you like me to
page 279 it's on page 28 of the document
please it's upper right
thank you
the page 279 that was yeah yes sir thank
you um
and online are you there
do you have the document up
on online
no i'm sorry is it in your hand okay
great
on page or
line 11 of page 279 you were asked the
question question did your sister
express anxiety to you about your drug
intake at around this time
your answer my sister christy has over
many many years
since my youth
had a number of worries about my
consumption growing up
yes she talked to me she talked to me
many times over the course of my life
and yes with misheard we did speak about
it
i think she and miss herd's ability to
speak to one another stopped not long
after this
did i read that right you did
when you first started seeing amber you
had um
you filmed the room diary but then you
went a couple years without
being involved and then you you saw each
other on the press tour for the movie
right
that's correct
and when you first started seeing her
after that couple year
uh period of not seeing her you had just
been checked out of a new york hospital
where you had been for a couple days to
fight alcohol use
correct um
yes and you were drinking uh you were
you were abusing alcohol toward the end
of your relationship with
your prior partner vanessa parody
correct
i was drinking
you were drinking pretty heavily
were you there
it's my question to you sir
no i wasn't drinking
i mean
let's turn to the uk
what you
define as heavily so
let's just look at what you said before
let's go to page 116 of the uk
transcript please this would be in day
one sixteen
yes sir 116 it was yes
yeah 116
um
down onto 117
okay
on 116
line
18 the question is i think one of the
problems in that relationship was your
alcohol and drug addiction misuse if you
prefer that word answer
i would definitely say towards the end
of my relationship with miss parady the
mother of my children
it was a very painful time to break up
with someone that you've been with for
14 years and that you have two children
with
so it was a very painful time and i was
more than likely trying to numb myself
as much as possible
question
am i right in saying that you agree that
you are abusing alcohol and drugs but
you have explained why
answer
i would say that i was abusing alcohol
i do not know that i was abusing drugs
but i was abusing alcohol for sure
yes
did i read that right you did
and there was a time in the early stages
of your relationship with amber when you
explained to her that you weren't
drinking alcohol at that time because
you had a problem with your liver
correct
um
yes there was uh
yeah there was there was concern over
the uh
the numbers
uh as they call it over my uh
about my liver um
and you shared that with amber right
yes i did
and
amber
early on your relationship throughout
your relationship
she didn't love the fact that you were
drinking and using drugs correct you've
testified to that many times objection
calls for speculation as to what miss is
in his heart's mind i'll sustain a step
forward if you want to rephrase you
understood that misheard was not happy
with you you overusing alcohol or
overusing drugs correct
um
from the very beginning yeah she was
trying to be supportive of your sobriety
correct
no sir no okay let's look at exhibit 182
please
are we in day two now
or is this no sorry this is this is a
this is an exhibit yeah you can set that
to the side sir thank you
this is an email
from exchange
from you
um
between you and elton john
in 2013 july 2013
correct
correct okay
um
and
the second email down is an email that
you sent to elton john
uh 505 in the afternoon on
july 13th 2013. you see that
yes i do okay uh your honor uh move for
the admission of exhibit 182 and
permission to publish
as soon as redactions need to be done
yes your honor there's some email
addresses in here and i would ask that
the portions that are not mr depths also
be redacted as well all right that's
fine okay so no objection with those
redactions is that correct
okay
let's just get those redactions
um
is it just one page
all right
i believe that covers the redactions
your honor may i just sure have a moment
to read absolutely
okay
no objection with the appropriate
reduction right 182 in evidence
and protections
thank you your honor
so this is this is an email that you
sent to elton john july 13 2013 and
michelle could you scroll down to the
third paragraph up from the bottom that
starts with the words on the other side
of the coin
and in that paragraph you write
on the other side of the coin
my kids have fallen head over heels in
deep love with amber my girl
and that pressure off my shoulders is
[ __ ] gone
that is
until the french extortionist
parentheses
x [ __ ]
attempts to brainwash them against her
which i'm sure is imminent
i i read that right didn't i you did
read that very well and
the
uh when you refer to the french
extortionist
um
and called her an ex-cunt you were
referring to vanessa parody the mother
of your children correct
yes sir things got a little um
at that point
between us
as they would
can you pull up exhibit 214 please
defendants exhibit 214.
mr depp portions of this we've already
seen portions of this uh of this exhibit
what i i'm going to ask you about the
top three messages these are messages
um to and from your daughter lily rose
i believe on february 4th 2014. correct
we object your honor these are
communications
we objected the admission of any
communications from his daughter what's
the legal objection uh hearsay
all right so first of all i was just
asking if
that was what it was but um
may we approach okay
mr depp you understood um
that
the last few years before amber
that
your relationship with your kids was
such that there was a perception by them
that you weren't around for them and
that all changed when amber came into
your life correct
objection calls for speculation
just asking what he's aware of um i'll
allow it
may i have a question one more time
you're aware
sure you're aware that the last few
years before
you started dating amber that there was
a perception by your kids that you
weren't around and that that all changed
when amber came into your life
um
th this is uh
not exactly the truth uh what you're
trying to put forth no i'm just asking
if you were aware that
of my question that there was a
perception that you weren't around for
the last couple years before amber and
that that changed when amber came into
your life that's that's all i'm asking
aston answered your honor
they were extenuating circumstances that
interviews the answer but without
objection i'll overrule that objection
thank you
um
you're also aware that there was a
perception you you were made aware that
lily rose believed that amber was a good
influence on you and changed you for the
better
correct objection hearsay your honor i'm
just asking for what his understanding
is i'll sustain the objection let's move
on okay all right
very briefly
answer that question sustainability
that's fine next question
you're aware of the uh the links that
miss heard went to
to
care for you when you were impaired on
drugs or alcohol correct
you'd have to be specific okay please
let's let's be s
specific sorry can you please pull up um
exhibit 839 your honor this is a
recording
um
and we plan to play
six
minutes and 55 seconds
through seven minutes and 29 seconds
is this a recording we already have in
no this i don't know
i i
i
i don't believe so but i'm not 100 sure
if this has been
8 39
8 the defendant's 839 is there any
objection to that audio recording
i don't believe assuming this is an
audio recording between mr def and miss
her then we have no objection
okay
thank you ron
and so no objection to it being entered
evidence correct that's correct and it's
full content but we're just playing a
portion of it as well that's exactly
right all right
evidence then okay thank you and
permission to play um the the
clip mentioned to the jury okay i assume
there's no objection since it's in
that's fine go ahead
i'm sure by pounding on the door waking
up every 15 minutes and then falling
asleep next to the door if i could hear
you snore in case that you vomited i
could call a mess if you ever stop
i
snoring
i
would choke on your own vomit which is
very likely with you really yes very
much
yes
what
yes you do vomit a lot in your sleep
even more
oh it's new to you
then this is affecting you a lot more
than i thought it was
can you please pull up defendants
exhibit 1094.
your honor may we approach
mr depp do you recognize this picture as
being a picture of you
yes mr kindly showed it to me the day
after she took it yes okay
um
this picture
i'd move for the admission of exhibit
defendants exhibit 1094 and ask for
permission to publish your honor
we have no objection your honor
this is a picture of you on a on a black
leather couch passed out correct
past that's an interesting way of
putting it maybe asleep
where is it what what residence in
boston
i'm sorry that was in boston when i was
doing black mass in boston and that's
that's ice cream on your lap correct
it is indeed uh miss herd asked me to
hold the ice cream as she noticed that i
was on on the nod that means falling
asleep
um from the
17-hour day that i'd worked and also the
opiates that i'd ingested
and if you'll notice
my right hand is in my pocket
so i
wasn't participating in the festival of
ice cream
okay um i was holding her ice cream
and um
because she knew
what was going to happen that i would
fall asleep and it would drop and that
was a wonderful picture to take for her
sure i don't know why she took it what
so it's misheard's fault that that
picture was taken that's that what
you're saying
she snapped it okay all right let's um
let's talk about this because you say
you were in boston this is when you were
filming black mass yes and you you
testified that that was
kind of the last film that you did um
when you were
you you were taking opiates right yes it
was right before the
the trip to the island
and you testified yesterday that um
opiates you don't take opiates to get
high right
you you've testified to that on a couple
different occasions correct you
[Music]
certainly can take opiates to get high
if
i doubled the dose
then i would most assuredly
be
ready for sleep
that's not a blackout that's
sure so if you double
if you double the dose you'd be ready
for sleep but it's it wouldn't get you
high
in the way that other other drugs would
correct
well the the the high is there's
it's it's a
extreme downer
um
it it
that's its job right and and for that
reason i believe you testified yesterday
or two two days ago it's not like you
take those pills to get high you
remember giving him that testimony
correct
um i said that it's it's not like i took
the pills to get high
i took the bills to be normal to stay
normal so let's pull up 866 please
what number did you say i'm sorry
defendants exhibit 866.
but i also believe that i said that i
asked
nurse
or i told nurse debbie
that
i had told her that i needed
more
than i actually took because i always
wanted to have one
or two in my pocket just in case
the
kick started
if you could take a look at the um
the text at the top of that page um yes
it's a text text exchange between you
and aaron borum aaron borem you
testified as one of dr kipper's nurses
right
yes
and this is a text exchange that you had
with her
uh in
august and september 2016. correct
so i'm looking for the oh yes yes uh
which one are we looking at here
the top three and in the first she tells
you that she's watching black mass
for the third time right on yeah so
august 30th yes yep
and
um
your honor i'd move for i'd like to
admit this exhibit um 866.
and permission to publish please and
particularly i'm talking about the top
three texts
so redacting the other text just the top
three texts and the identity yes
yes your honor your honor we have no
objection but we would ask that the
fourth text message be included as well
as contact for text sure
and obviously the phone number's
redacted as well of course let's get
that up let's see what that looks like
um
um
all right
that's an objection yeah okay 181 i'm
sorry 866 in evidence with reductions
thank you your honor michelle could you
blow up that third text it starts with
you or the sweetest
please
and in this text to miss borum
after she's telling you that she's
watching black mass for the third time
in a row you write i was high as a
[ __ ] when i made that film
hahaha you see that
did i read that right yes you did read
that right okay
now you can take that down
you've trashed hotel rooms before simply
because you've had a bad couple days and
an unpleasant time correct
i have assaulted a couch or two yes sir
you'd agree that at times in your life
you've expressed yourself through
destructive behavior
um
yes
and you'd agree that
at times when you were angry you smashed
things up right
more in my um
uh
confused sort of youth yes and you said
in an interview one time you said the
following quote you know you have bad
days and you know some guys go play golf
some guys you know smash hotel rooms
you've said that before right
it was um
just a yes or no question you've said
that before right i said it as a joke
you believe that if something feels
stronger than you that it's a human
reflex to smash something or throw
something against the wall or punch a
door correct
i don't believe that i'm the only human
being that's ever punched a door or
broken something in a in a uh
an internal
uh
bout with myself
you believe that that's unique in that
way you believe that that's something
that happens when you get frustrated
right and that it's a mini explosion
that comes and goes quickly you agree
with that right when i was younger it
was it was uh
it was a little bit
more accessible if if you will let's
pull up exhibit 143 please
can you scroll down
because this is an email exchange
between you and steven deuters your
personal assistant uh in april of 2019
you see
that yes and it's it's two pages i
believe so let's go to the second page
please
um or that the bottom of right there um
and
you see that on april 19th 2012 you
wrote him i got drunk and destroyed my
room there are hookers and animals in
here did i read that right
yes you did you're on a permission to or
i'd like to move for admission of
defendants exhibit 143 and permission to
publish please
as long as the email uh
addresses are redacted we have no
objection your honor all right just
redacting the email addresses but the
full content comes in is that correct
yes
make sure i got it straight okay
dac identified identifiers
all right
you agree let's just can we just let's
make sure that that's the only is that
the only email address
okay
all right okay wait a minute could you
go down to the second page again for a
second go down to the second page please
can we just see the top again i just
let's go to the top
the top of the top of the first page
thanks
okay thank you
okay do you mind if i read this or
you're going to read this to me
we're going to we're going to take a
look at it all right 143 in evidence you
can
okay
thank you your honor um can you scroll
down michelle
so you write to mr deuters i got drunk
and destroyed my room there are hookers
and animals in here and then if you
scroll up
he writes simply watch out for mike
tyson have you num numbed
uh correct and then you write
don't want nummies thank you
is it okay to put on a condom after the
fact i mean if i just wear it for the
rest of the day like that works doesn't
it
i've had to kill a few of the animals
for sustenance i've made quite a mess
there's blood and animal tracks
everywhere i read that right
you did okay
and you're you are currently um
uh in a lawsuit for assaulting a crew
member on the set of one of your movies
in july 2018 correct
um
yes someone brought a case against me
right a man by the name of greg rocky
brooks is a suing you for allegedly
punching him twice and um
uh
mr depp i'm not going to ask you any
questions about the particulars of that
lawsuit
but
other than this the two bodyguards who
were with you on the set
of the movie
on the day that's the subject of that
lawsuit were sean bett and jerry judge
correct that's correct
your honor can we please take the um
example sure yeah we can take that down
down thank you
i'd like to to shift gears and and talk
about uh um
talk about hicksville you remember
taking a trip to a place called the
hicksville trailer palace in late may
2013 correct i do indeed how could i
forget and the people this is it's like
a little mini trailer resort out near
palm springs joshua tree area
that's correct um and the people that
were there with you on that trip were
amber her sister whitney right
um a woman by the name of christy sexton
right oh yes okay
um rocky pennington yes right um someone
named kelly sue kelly sue milano milano
or kelly sue eater you got me
you remember you remember kelly sue
right
i i don't remember a kelly sue okay uh
well in fact you you kelly sue
you'll recall was sitting close to
amber and and
you thought she was being affectionate
toward her
you'd agree with that right
sitting close is not the description i
would uh give it myself
well you just satisfied you didn't
remember someone named kelly sue but i'm
i'm putting it to you you remember
someone named kelly sue who was sitting
close to amber and being affectionate
and you took exception to that didn't
you i wasn't aware that her name was
kelly sue terribly sorry about that
i didn't know her name
but
it was someone i'd never seen before
who
had clearly taken
some happy something and was
very affectionate with
my uh
girlfriend
and so you removed kelly sue's hand from
amber and you yelled at kelly sue and
told her that amber was your girl right
that's not correct that's not correct no
sir
not in the way that you're saying it
i certainly did remove her hand from
amber
that's the answer to your question
but
i think it's not
well
mr depp it's not it's not a matter of
how i said it it's a matter of how
you've said it so let's take a look at
page 239 of the uk transcript please
this will be day two
2 29
239 230 page 18.
sorry that's all right a lot of papers
um
239 yes
it's going to be 239 and 240. okay
thank you
and you see
on page 239
line
22 you're being asked a question about
um the incident we've just been
discussing and you're asking a question
and how did you deal with that
uncomfortable situation where are you
reading from
page 239 line 22
22 okay yep you got it
yes i do all right
question and how did you deal with that
uncomfortable situation answer i removed
miss kelly sue's hand from miss herd's
body and i told her do not do that that
first of all
that is my girl
second of all it is rude and invasive
she was quite glassy eyed and she seemed
pretty unsure of her surroundings she
seemed very unstable on her feet and i
remember saying to her if you were going
to take this drug mdma you should know
if you were able to handle it or not
correct
did i read that right that's correct
and after this
uh incident you went back into the
trailer that you and miss heard were
were sharing and you had a big argument
right
yes there was an argument and the
argument started about kelly sue correct
amber was unhappy with your reaction to
her and what happened correct objection
calls for speculation i i i'll sustain
the objection and you could you had an
argument with ms heard and you
understood her to be upset with the way
that you had handled um that situation
with kelly sue correct
i i mean i recall that
that was a a part of the argument but um
as i had told miss hurd i was
sorry if this i mean i was protecting
miss herd's
honor and i was protecting my girl
from someone who was clearly
unable to
deal with the
substances that she'd taken
forward
and i i know that there will be
differing accounts of what happened in
that trailer uh over the course of this
trial but you would agree with me mr
depp that
at a minimum you smashed up a bathroom
sconce during that argument correct
yes sir i punched i punched a um a glass
a
bathroom sconce
right by the mirror and i apologize
we've already covered this but this trip
was in late may 2013. i don't wish okay
if you could pull up exhibit 181
uh michelle
this has already been admitted into
evidence this morning your honor
no i don't have 181 in ever did we not
oh you know what i forgot that this
morning i'm sorry so 181
um
yep that's right yeah we we haven't
looked at this one yet this morning mr
depp i'm going to ask you about um
the the third text down this is a text
exchange from
you
a text message from you
to paul bettany
on july 11 2013 right
yes okay and then above that there's a
text message exchange
between you and your sister christy on
july 10 2013.
correct
the text above it yes yeah um your honor
i'd move for the admission of exhibit
181 with of just those three texts
uh no objection your honor with the
property reduction all right get those
redactions done thank you
i'm sorry
um could you please clarify which text
messages are going to be offered the top
three top three
thank you yes
there we go
all right any objection than that to
those reductions
no objection okay 181 in evidence with
redactions
thank you your honor all right
um on if i'd like to take a look at the
text that you sent to paul bettany on
july 11th if you could blow that up
please michelle
and we just talked about this trip to
hicksville
um if you
just yeah there we go um if you go to
the second paragraph or the kind of the
fourth line down you write to mr betany
missing you and yours
and await our dangle on the island
you may have to drink for me
i of course
pounded
and displayed ugly colors to amber on a
recent journey
i am an insane person
and not so fair-headed after too much of
the drink
weed pills
fine
booze
my capacity is too large and i won't
stop
ugly and sad
oh how i love it
did i read that right
you did
if you go up please this is a text
message from
exchange between you and christy
in which christy texts you
she wants to talk to me
she doesn't know what to do
loves you but doesn't know always what
to do she's worried about it all
and you write to her it was not pleasant
today
i wasn't aware she had another goddamn
photo shoot tomorrow
that's really why she [ __ ] left
i don't need actress [ __ ] and her
[ __ ] ambition
that's what you wrote
to your sister about amber on july 10th
2013. do i read that right you did
i'd like to turn to you can take that
down michelle i'd like to turn to the
the boston plane flight that we've
talked about a little bit in the trial
yes
the night before the flight and sorry if
we covered some of this but just to
orient the jury to the sequence of
events the night before the flight miss
heard was in new york
and you were picked up
in boston by private jet so the the jet
that you chartered picked miss herd up
uh along with savannah mcmillan and then
flew to boston and picked you up along
with some other people is that right
that's correct and then all of you flew
back to los angeles that's correct and
the night before that you were due to
meet up uh to take this plane flight
you and miss heard had a heated
discussion on the phone about scenes
that she was doing in a movie with james
franco right i don't recall what the
argument was about there was
there are many to uh let's go to page
293 of your
uk transcript please yes
did i say 290 293
yes okay
and on line 22
you were asked the question the night
before you were due to meet up did you
have a heated discussion on the
telephone with miss heard about what was
happening with james franco the scene
she was doing with james james franco
answer i do not recall but it is highly
likely did i read that right
in fact i'm not sure where you are
okay
um day two page 293 it's on page 32 of
the document line 22 i think is the
issue
page 32 line 22. thank you your honor
line 22. i'm 22 on page 32. yes too many
too many numbers
are you there
yes yes okay so
question the night before you were due
to meet up did you have a heated
discussion on the telephone with miss
heard about what was happening with
james franco the scene she was doing
with james franco answer i do not recall
but it is highly likely did i read that
right
you did and you suspected that amber was
having an affair with james franco
correct
that was the reason for your argument
um
yeah yes and when you got on the plane
you considered that she was also
being judgmental toward you because she
believed that you were inebriated and
under the influence of drugs correct
that was a constant
and i'm talking about this particular
plane flight well
you consider that she was being
judgmental toward you because she
believed you were inebriated and under
the influence of drugs when you got on
this plane correct
yes
and at some point on the flight you
ended up sleeping on the bathroom floor
right i did
you testified to that yesterday correct
yes sir and when you landed you were you
were quite ill
when you landed in los angeles
correct
i don't recall being quite ill
i
it's possible i don't know
what you're referring to
let's take a look at me there paige yeah
sure let's take a look at page 313 of
your uk transcript please
it's on page 37 of the document
may we appreciate it all right
for a second
mr def do you have page 313 in front of
you i do sir okay can you just
read uh you can read to yourself
the um
the
uh page 313
line 14 that starts with the word were
okay
and then read that
question and answer
yes sir
does that refresh your recollection that
you were quite ill when you landed in
los angeles
um
yes
but it doesn't uh
refer to the me being ill on the plane
um sure okay
um we'll we'll we'll get to the plane
ride in a few minutes
we just did let's let's turn to exhibit
236 please
defendants exhibit
sorry i've got a mess going on over here
i've um
yeah
it's on the screen
oh
and i don't have a mess so excuse me
these are text messages that you sent to
amber
on may 25th 2014 the day after that
plane flight correct yes okay yes
um you're on our uh move for the
admission of exhibit 236 and ask for
permission to publish with the um with
identifiers redacted no objection your
honor all right if you could just redact
those identifiers
all right 236 in evidence with the
redactions
and uh thank you
okay
blow up the top email please
and in this email to
amber
the day after this plane flight
you write her and you say once again
i find my place sorry start over once
again i find myself in a place of shame
and regret
of course i am sorry
i really don't know why or what happened
but i will never do it again
i want to get better for you
and for me i must
my illness somehow crept up and grabbed
me
i can't do it again
i can't live like that again
and i know you can't either
i must get better
and i will
for us both starting today
i love you again
i'm so sorry so sorry
i love you and feel so bad for letting
you down
yours
did i read that right
you did
and let's pull up exhibit 245 one more
time which has uh been admitted into
evidence uh this morning your honor
mr deppa i know that we've seen this
before this morning
but your email that i just read to you
to misheard or your text
was from may 25th 2014.
five days later
you text your good friend paul bettany
and you tell him
that you had drank all night before you
picked up amber to fly to la
you tell them that you had no food for
days
powders
which is cocaine right
powder's just cocaine right sure yeah
half a bottle of whiskey
a thousand red bull and vodkas
pills
two bottles of champers on plane
and then you write what do you get
an angry
agro engine in a [ __ ] blackout
screaming obscenities and insulting any
[ __ ] who got near
i am i'm done
i am admittedly too [ __ ] in the head
to spray my rage at the one i love
for little reason as well
i'm too old to be that guy
but pills are fine
did i read that right you did
now the two tuba you can well you can
leave that up the two bottles of
champagne on the plane
that was about when you wrote two
bottles of champagne on the plane that
was about the plane ride from boston to
l.a correct
yes it comes just after a thousand cans
of red bull and at least two at least
parts of that plane flight you were in a
blackout right
there's a
the
there's no reason you tell paul bettany
that you were in a blackout if it wasn't
true correct
there are
again when i
when i write something when i write a
text
especially if i'm in a
um
particularly
impassioned
place
it's
it's it's it's it's a canvas it's a
painting right
now you appreciate that that wasn't my
question sir my question was very simple
okay would you agree that at least on
parts of that plane flight you were in a
blackout
uh
no i wouldn't agree that i'm i was in a
blackout let's look at
let's look at page 333 of your
transcript
333
this is day two
this is from the uk trial
yes we seem to be there a lot
your honor may we approach please okay
do you see that page mr depp
333 yes i do okay and you see on line 8
you were asked a question question but
parts of that flight are blacked out
answer
apparently but yes apparently that is
what i'm saying to mr betany
question yes
is there any reason why you would say
that to mr betany if it were not true
answer probably not
did i read that right
you did
and it's you would agree that on that
flight you were very drunk and that you
had taken drugs either before or during
the flight correct
i know that i
well i knew that
i was going to have a very ugly
um
i was going to end up with a very ugly
situation with amber
with respect to trying to respect the
court's time and the jury sign that was
not my question my question was
you would agree
you would agree you would agree that on
that flight
you were very drunk and you had taken
drugs either before or during
or both
catching compound all right sustain
you would agree
that you were very drunk on that flight
correct
i do not agree that i was very drunk on
that flight and you would agree that you
had taken drugs either before or during
that flight correct i had taken a double
dose of the
um oxycodone
which is different than a blackout but
but you don't agree that you were very
drunk
i i don't recall
drinking a whole you don't need to drink
a whole lot when you're on those things
you don't have time you just testified
you weren't drunk on the flight okay i i
don't recall being drunk all right let's
let's look at page 335 of your uk
testimony okay mr rotten
where would you like to start
line 11 please
you are asked a question
i want to question i want to make sure
it is quite clear what you are saying
about the boston plane incident you were
very drunk you had taken drugs either
before or during or both do you agree
with that
answer sure for the purposes of getting
through this let's say yes
everything you have said
i agree
did i read that right
you did
um i was caving in
from that
uh can we pull up
um exhibit 243 please
actually no you know what let's go to
exhibit 221.
your honor this is um this is a
recording um and i'd be happy to read
we're gonna play three three uh
excerpts from it okay and there's no
objections the entire audio recording
coming in is that correct
um can can may we approach i would just
like to know what it is first
okay
your honor um
we would offer the
the full exhibit 221 into evidence with
the following three excerpts to be
played
the first is the start of the audio
through one minute
i just want the first full minute and
then 2 50 through 3 20 2 minutes and 50
seconds through 3 20
and then 9 30 through 10 minutes all
right please so 2 21 entirely in
evidence but you play those excerpts
uh
[Music]
oh
that's your voice making those moaning
sounds
sound like an animal in pain right mr
depp
that's uh that's exactly what i uh i
said before yes that is uh sounds like a
pained animal maybe that's my voice
please
[Music]
and then let's go play 9 30 please
[Music]
shoes
[Music]
get sick
[Music]
mr depp do you know who the male voice
is um who at around 9 41 says no i'm
going to stay with this [ __ ] idiot in
case he gets sick
you know his voice i didn't hear those
words but um
all right yes that's jerry judge
if you wanted me to answer that that was
jerry judge's voice okay so
you
you you finish this flight
you send the text that we've seen to
amber you send the text to paul bettany
and
at some point after this you decide that
you want to go to detox and you went to
detox you testified a little bit about
it yesterday in august of 2014
in the bahamas correct
the recording of the pain noises is not
from that flight sir
um
not my question my question is you went
to detox in august 2014
right don't recall exactly
and you were there on the island with on
the island yes
you were there on the island with uh
amber
and debbie lloyd and dr kipper correct
that's correct
you and amber were on one side of the
island right
yes
and amber was effectively dedicating
herself to your well-being during this
detox process correct
you could describe it as that as uh
at the beginning yes certainly she was
trying to help you get through it right
one would think and
as far as you know she's never been in
any sort of detox in her life right
certainly not when you were together
correct
no i don't think so okay and
we we all heard your testimony yesterday
detox
it sounds painful it sounds tough
fair
um yes that's
um
and you
you testified yesterday
about her
not giving you medications at a certain
time but you sir have you have no
personal knowledge of
whether
or when amber had been in touch with
dr kipper or debbie lloyd about when to
give you medicine correct
um
[Music]
no personal knowledge of that yes i do i
remember amber calling them on the radio
and
when i was
complaining that i needed
the meds when i was in
agony and went to the shower she called
them up because she had said that i was
in a manic state or it was in some mania
um and they came up there
okay and sometime after detox
fair and you heard you said that they
came up there but my point to you is you
have no personal knowledge of what dr
kipper or debbie lloyd communicated to
amber about whether and when to give you
medicines you weren't part of those
communications correct
oh sure i was i was there during during
um
those
discussions
there were times
times sort of written down but
you know the golden rule essentially is
if the patient is in an uncomfortable or
uh
dangerous potentially dangerous state
which would lead to seizures
uh medication be should be distributed
that's what i remember
even though if it was supposed to be
delivered at 4 00 p.m and it was 3 15 or
3 30 i
you know according to you that's what
you you recall the golden rule was right
yes i mean that's what doctors and
patients and after some time after detox
you texted amber and you said
thank you so much for getting me [ __ ]
clean baby
right remember that yes i did okay and
you um
actually let's pull up
you you didn't just express your thanks
to amber you expressed it to other
people as well what amber had done for
you correct let's pull up exhibit
plaintiffs exhibit
120 page 41 please
this is plaintiff's exhibit your honor
thank you
is this a screen thing or am i searching
for something this is a screen thing
okay thank you
the screen thing that we have to rotate
and
the the only
question i have for you are is the
the question on
the top
of the page yes
sent on august 19
2014
from you to page now page is amber's mom
right
that's correct okay um you're on our
move for the admission of um just this
page of this exhibit with just that text
and the
identifiers redacted
which page of this exhibit is it
i'm sorry which page of the exhibit is
it's
page 41. page 41. or it's listed as
exhibit
120
four
underscore0041
okay
one twenty we'll just make it a page
four one
that sounds good your honor thank you
age 41
and
we want it redacted
so just to be clear if it's just the top
text message and the identifiers are
removed we have no objection okay so we
can stack that that way
thank you you're on and just that page
yes yes sure page 41.
okay all right so 128 and evidence as
we're back
permission to publish your honor yes yes
sir thank you
mr depp this is in this text that you
send to
page heard
amber's mom on august 19 2014.
you say the following and i understand
that you gave certain testimony
yesterday about
what you perceived miss herd's
a role in your detox to be but but on
this date you sent this text to misheard
to pageherd and you say
i couldn't have made it without her
i would have gone for a swim
and swallowed a big drink of ocean
without her to be honest
it was a hell of my own doing and your
little girl
walked through with me step by step
i know you're already proud of her but
if you'd have seen her in action amazing
it was an exercise of monumental
patience and instinct
i wouldn't be alive sweetheart
there were more than a few times when i
thought it would be more simple to take
that route
it was amber and amber only that got me
through this and it was not easy
thank you for her first
and thank you and that sweet [ __ ]
david for all of your words of support
i'm through the other side now i think i
hope all this boy's love your son outlaw
did i read that right you did too
you can take that down
thank you
now you flew
uh you got married to to amber on uh
early february february 3rd 2015. is
that right okay
um
you remember the year today
2015 right
that sounds about right okay
and
a week after your wedding
um
you left for australia to
start
the process of shooting the fifth
pirates of the caribbean movie right
that sounds about right yes and amber
was filming in london at the time she
left directly from the wedding to fly to
london to film london fields with billy
bob thornton right that's correct
and the plan was that she was going to
fly out from london
to australia directly to join you for
the filming of pirates 5 right
at some point yes and she was going to
stay in that house with you for the
duration of the filming correct
um
i don't know that it was the duration
but i uh sure okay
and you testified on
tuesday i guess that when you went there
in february of 2015 you'd been off of
alcohol for 18 months you testified to
that remember giving that testimony um
yes
that's just nonsense right we've already
looked at thank you may may 2014
you were drunk on that plane and you've
admitted to that
that's not 18 months before
so that testimony that you gave when you
said you had been sober for 18 months
before you arrived in february of 2015
was not true correct what's the
objection may we approach your honor
what's the objection
he's testifying your honor
it's a compound could you just do me one
question let's do that
mr depp you had not been sober
off of alcohol for 18 months before you
went to australia in february 2015.
correct
uh it's possible that it was
not 18 months maybe it was 17 maybe it
was 16 it was actually a lot less than
that because at a minimum you were drunk
on that plane flight from boston to los
angeles in may of 2014. that's incorrect
sir i said that i had a glass of
champagne and i had taken a double dose
of the narcotics of the opiates
that's a very different thing from being
drunk okay and a very different thing
from what you texted paul bettany
correct
again okay so
she you you the boston flight was in may
2014 you go to australia in february of
2015
having testified that you were off
alcohol for 18 months now
when you went to australia
in february of 2015 you also
lied to the cast insurance company that
was insuring you for pirates five didn't
you
after
she cut my finger off no no well that's
your your account of it sir before you
went to australia
you
let's do it this way let's pull up
exhibit 500 please 500 500 defense
exhibit
500. yes i'd like to see who i lied
to mr depp you see this is a it's called
a cast insurance medical certificate
correct
uh yes i see that yes okay
and
it's dated this is in um
i believe it's in
the the not the way we do dates in the
u.s because you can see
on the the lower left column examinee
start date of filming
16 to february february
2015. so that means february 16 2015.
correct correct
and the date of the exam before we be
before we go any further we'd ask to be
able to see this entire document
i'm just asking about the top of it
that's i'm
happy if we want
there's specific parts i'm asking about
but if we want to they want to scroll
through with that it's unclear whether
mr depp has ever even seen this so we
just
appreciate the courtesy of being able to
see the entire document
that's fine your honor
i mean i i'm gonna direct him to certain
parts of it but that's fine if they
wanna
i'm just trying to move things along
here
i'm sorry
i have a hard copy if you'd like to look
at that
they'd like to see page three
oh if if i may approach your honor that
would be
oh
it's
what i'm confused what
they just scrolled to the last page so
we can just view it here thank you
okay
thank you sorry i appreciate that
good mr rottenborn your question yes i
do um
mr deb this is your signature on the
page of the document being displayed
here correct that is and it's dated uh
february 11 2015.
correct
um your honor with the understanding
that if the exhibit for the court will
have to redact signatures i'd move
for admission of this document and
permission to publish
any objection
uh your honor this is might have some
medical information so at this time we'd
like an opportunity to ensure
this this is an insurance form with
medical information i just want to make
sure we're not publishing anything that
shouldn't be your honor's made clear
that anything that comes into evidence
in this case will be published to the
jury
whether it's
medical information that your honor has
already ruled is not admissible
approach please come here
okay
and then
okay and then can you can you scroll
down michelle
scroll down again
okay
you're on the these redactions were on
here before we i'm told before we got
the documents so no no issue there and
then
um we would propose to just redact the
um
if you go up one page
i don't
that's that's the proposed reduction
and if if you want us to redact the
the first two
the first three lines m n and that's
fine too
why don't you go ahead and redact those
michelle
that's fine
i'm just trying to move this along as
quickly as we can your honor
all right all right
500 in evidence with the redactions
when you have agreed redactions
okay yes
thank you your honor so we looked at
your signature mr mr depp if scroll
scroll down please michelle um
two more pages there's your signature
and then this is a it's an insurance
form for
um
for your that the studio disney took out
for your
um for you
filming pirates five correct
i don't i don't i guess so yes okay and
you see the role here
uh it's listed as captain jack sparrow
johnny depp coverage status full
coverage effective date february 11
2015. right
i see that and you're aware it's not
uncommon for studios to want to ensure
um
actors that are playing in a movie in
case something happens right
it's it's happens
30 plus years for me correct
um so if you can scroll up please and in
order to do that you have to provide
certain information to see if you're
insurable right correct okay
and in this document which you signed
dated i believe february 11th you were
asked the question
um are you currently using uh or in the
last 12 months have you used any of the
following
michelle let's let's unredact the um
well there's section b is illegal
substances whether prescribed by a
physician or not
and you check the box to the right
michelle could you is there a way to
unredact
that
the headers in that column so we can see
which one is yes and which one is no
thank you
so
mr depp when you were asked the question
in this cast insurance form are you
currently using or in the past last 12
months have you used any of the
following you say yes that you've used
some prescription drugs and when in the
question that says illegal substances
whether prescribed by a physician or not
you
check no
correct
yes
at around this time when you were you
can take that down thank you at around
this time when you flew to australia in
february of 2015
you were
um
you were starting to feel
depressed about your role in pirates and
your acting legacy generally correct
well let's do it this way let's let's
put up exhibit 350. please go ahead and
take our lunch sure thank you okay all
right ladies let's go ahead and take our
lunch break and go to 210 okay so uh
don't talk to anybody don't discuss the
case and don't do the outside research
and we'll see you back at 210 okay
this
all right so we'll take a recess till
210 all right thank you
210.
we ready for the jury good afternoon
your honor we actually do have a very
brief preliminary sure that's we could
approach okay
all right let's go and get the jury
you
all right thank you see all right your
next question mr ruttenborn
thank your honor
good afternoon afternoon
um
michelle can you please pull up exhibit
175 please
defendants exhibit
mr depp is this uh an email exchange you
had with bruce witkin
um
on
june 6th june 7th 2013.
oh it's june 7th 2013. okay
and
um if you scroll down to the bottom
that that
i'm not going to read it aloud but that
email address is your email address is
that right
that
i don't oh yes yes yes yes sir okay um
thank you um so this email is an email
that you sent to to mr witkin on um june
6 2013 at 705 a.m the one that starts
with seriously be woozy
is that right that's correct okay and
bruce witkin was a long time friend of
yours right
yesterday played a long time
you met in florida many years ago right
yes and then he you he lived in los
angeles and you all were were very close
friends until a few years ago correct
that's correct okay
um you're on our permission to um
publish or move for admission of this
and permission to publish with the email
addresses redacted and if they want me
to redact mr witkin's responses that's
fine
uh we have no objection to that your
honor and i don't think we need to have
mr waken's response redacted all right
so you just want to have um just the
identifiers redacted and that's all
that's correct okay if we could do that
all right
okay now i know this is a few years
before uh australia um in 2015 which we
we stopped with right before lunch
but i want to just if you can scroll
down um
michelle please to the paragraph that
starts brain is on full tilt
and maybe just blow up the first
couple sentences there okay yeah perfect
um so in this email to mr witkin in june
of 2013
you write to him brain is on full tilt
the circus never stops
feel physically [ __ ] constantly
i'm wired up so tight that i'm barely
able to deal with people on any level
that is remotely enjoyable
you see that i read that right
yes i see yes now michelle can you
please pull up exhibit 350 defendants
exhibit 350.
[Music]
this is a text exchange that you had
with stephen duders your personal
assistant on march 6 2015. so we fast
forwarded a couple years do you see that
is that 16
28 is it the third one down
uh yes yes sir 1628
third one down
and this is a text that you sent to mr
duders on march 6 2015.
so i just read again
yes
and it by this point you had been in
australia since
about the week after your wedding right
so for three weeks or so is that about
right
seems right yes okay and amber didn't
arrive until around this time correct
beginning in march
yes
i recall that amber arrived around
sixth seventh the sixth or seventh of
march right okay so you've been been
outside of her presence for the last
three or four weeks prior to this right
i believe
okay um can you uh your honor i would
move for admission of defense exhibit
350 with identifiers redacted
you're on we would ask that the top
email to mr
um holmes and the last email from mr
deuters be redacted just the two in the
middle yes sure and obviously you're on
a then if we're going to do that we can
just redact the um
actually we can redact the second one
too so we just do the just do the third
uh your honor we believe that's
necessary for contracts okay for context
sorry so just get rid of the first one
and the last one and the identifiers so
it should be the two middle texts
thank you if you could just 350 in
evidence
as redacted okay okay
thank you your honor um michelle if you
could blow up the email starting with
honestly so this is an email you've been
in uh pre-production and shooting in
pirates 5 for the last couple of weeks
correct
by march 6 2015.
what was the question sorry by march 6
2015 you've been in pre-production and
shooting for pirates five for a couple
of weeks in australia right i believe so
he is okay so your email to him to mr
duders your personal assistant
reads honestly
i will not again be doing anything that
involves the discussion of furthering my
embarrassment of having horde for all
these [ __ ] wasted pieces of [ __ ]
nothing years on characters that i so
ignorantly started to think of as my
legacy
every [ __ ] fight every [ __ ] time i
held my ugliness and rage deeper down
and get in check
when there was still room in my head to
do such a
did
thing
read that right you did and that's what
you're writing
uh to mr duders having been on the set
of pirates five for a couple of weeks
correct
that's correct yeah the screenplay that
i received was um
not um up to snuff i felt and so that
was part of this
was
my
anger was that the screenplay was very
lazily written
and i had to do a lot of rewriting
and
um with you in australia i think we
covered this was was debbie lloyd you
testified to that before lunch right
debbie lloyd was your sobriety nurse
trying to she's supposed to help help
you stay sober correct
well she was there to give me meds and
right
the fact is on the path
okay
uh the the fact is mr deputy you had you
had been using a fair fair amount of
drugs during those three or four week
period before miss heard arrived in
australia hadn't you
marijuana was what i was using and not
not just that other drugs too correct
no not that i recall no
let's take a look at exhibit 346 please
okay
this is a text message exchange between
you
and nathan holmes
on february 25th 2015.
correct
that's correct mr holmes was another one
of your personal assistants wasn't he
yes he was he and steven deuters were
kind of the
the the two main personal assistants
during this period of time right that's
correct okay
and
um
at the top of the page the second one
down do you see where mr holmes tells
you objection hearsay
he just testified that he was only using
marijuana and this is clearly
impeachment to that your honor this is
mr holmes
we're gonna we're gonna go text by text
and i'm but before i ask for permission
to publish uh and for motion for
admission we'll go through it but it
i'll sustain us mr holmes
okay
mr deb
why don't you why don't you take a
moment to read this text from the top
down thank you please
uh
okay
so
mr deb does does this refresh your
recollection that in fact you weren't
doing
just marijuana in late february 2015 in
fact you were doing cocaine
that nathan holmes was supplying to you
in fact there's nothing in there that
says i've been doing
cocaine does this refresh your
recollection mr depp that you were given
cocaine by nathan holmes in late
february 2015.
um even if i were given cocaine by
nathan holmes there's
no there's nothing here that says i was
doing the cocaine and nathan holmes was
upset or he he
you understood that nathan holmes
thought that you might be upset with him
for taking some of your cocaine
isn't that right
objection your honor hearsay and
speculation excuse me i said what was
his understanding i'll sustain his
speculation next question okay um and in
fact mr depp um you you also
were going to see marilyn manson
uh in australia around this time
correct
correct he was coming to play a show in
melbourne okay
um
your honor i would i would move for
admission of of this document with the
following um text messages we can redact
whatever else they want although i think
well
the ones that um
of the witnesses own words that i'd like
to show are
eight zero zero three nine
eight zero zero four one
eight zero zero eight six
those are all words from mr depp
i have a highlighted copy if you'd like
me to
approach yeah you we have no objection
as long as everything else is wrong look
at his highlighted copy and make sure
that's
touched the screen horribly
it's okay you're good
all set
okay so no objection to the redactions
uh
no objection to threefold with
reductions yes okay thank you look at
those redactions
all right 346 in evidence for the
redactions you can publish it
so you can see these texts were sent on
february 26th and february 27 2015 and
if you scroll over michelle and can you
just blow up the text portion of it
you text
mr holmes your personal assistant have
you heard from manson's ryan now ryan
was
marilyn manson's personal assistant or
he worked for him that's what you
understood correct at the time yes okay
and then you say
yes and yes and of course
yes please and you will pay ryan for it
two exclamation points two question
marks and then you write
disappear
we should have more happy pills
three exclamation points
two question marks
can you followed by three exclamation
points did i read that correctly
you did okay can you take that down and
please pull up um exhibit question 49
instead of exclamation points
and mr depp this
this text exchange that i'm going to ask
you about is from just two days later
after february 26th
on february 28th it's the last two on
the page
um
february 28 2015 there's a text from you
to mr duders i would object to the uh is
hearsay with respect to the text from mr
deuters that's fine okay you just see so
just the second to last one
is is all
we would seek to admit
okay if we could do the redactions for
just that
yes your honor and we'll
happy to redact uh mr duder's response
[Music]
all right so 349 in evidence with
redactions okay
thank you your honor
so in this text message mr depp
sent on february 28
2015
you res you you send
mr deuters an email and if you'll
remember what we had just looked at was
you reaching out to mr holmes asking if
he had heard from manson's assistant
ryan
and then saying yes and yes and yes of
course please pay ryan for it and then
asking for more happy pills and in this
text message you say yay
hello master d
i say
i do believe that ryan
parentheses
munson's
just gave you a wii baggage for me
where does it reside
x
did i read that right
you continue to read them right yes and
the that where it says munson's that's a
typo and should have said manson's
correct
uh
it's a nickname okay um you can take
that down
um
thank you
so we've gone from february 26th to
february 28th i'd now like to fast
forward to march 2nd of that year 2015.
can you please pull up exhibit 353.
in your honor i've um
well let's
let's do it this way um mr
depp these are text messages back and
forth from you to your
other personal assistant nathan holmes
um
in march of 2015.
correct
appears to be yes yes
um
your honor i know that the whole thing
is going to draw an objection but i um i
would like to to move to admit mr depp's
text which i have here highlighted i
think we can redact pretty quickly um
through this document and i'm happy to
have them highlighted if you'd like to
need to approach if you can just sure
to cancel the highlighted portions is
this a one-page document it's actually
it's actually three three and we may not
do all of them now but i think it's
easier to just
okay
michelle
yeah um we have no objection with just
admitting mr doubts okay 353 with the
redactions yes and i think we can
um if you'll just indulge us for a
minute i think we can get all of that
done thank you okay
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
all right so 353 in evidence with
actions
is that
is that correct
yes your honor
assuming that
miss myers agrees with with our
redactions here
can we just see the other pages before
the redactions were implemented
okay
yes awesome thank you 353 in evidence
with the redactions thank you you're
honest
can you please go to the first page of
that document
so
february 26th
february 28th now now we're up to march
2nd
and
on march 2nd
a few days before ms hurd arrives in
australia you test you text nathan
holmes
and
this is going to take a little bit just
to kind of get through this so i
appreciate the court and the jury's
patience here
but you text him on number 73 and you
say
no you're not
why
that is not a part of the job
description
and i'm telling you now
any one of any of you guys start to
lecture me
i just do not want to hear it
no stupid [ __ ] about sappy bollocks
i am a grown [ __ ] man
and i will not be judged
i read that right
you did keep going please
and i will never
ever
live
in this world cage any longer
i'll do whatever i damn well please
okay
did i read that right
you did
then if we go on to the next page
please
continue
and say
i don't want to depend on others for
things
like that
i'm not unhappy
i am insane
big difference
i read that right
you did
no system
then you say
i don't want to risk it for you
or anyone
so
i can get what i need
also may i be ecstatic again
helps
color me deceased
by ecstatic you're referring to taking
ecstasy correct
very likely before ms heard um arrived
she had asked me to
score
uh either mdma or ecstasy tablets before
her arrival okay so once again miss
herds at fault for these texts
um i'm not blaming you for the text i'm
just stating
the facts okay well let's let's let's
talk about those facts so okay this hurt
arrives in march in 2015.
you can go ahead and actually you know
what let's
let's go down uh one michelle because
we're gonna fast forward a few days and
and we're gonna we're gonna come back to
this actually just one day
this is when you text
uh mr
i don't remember if it was holmes or
duders at this point um mr holmes
correct
and you text him and you say this is
yeah
yeah so we fast forwarded another
couple of days i guess five days and you
say
need more whitey stuff asap brother man
and the e-business please
i'm in bad bad shape
say nothing to nobody
did i read that right you did so okay
and i wanted to take a look at that mr
depp
because
you just
testified that miss heard
uh was the one who wanted ecstasy but in
fact when you sent this text on march
7th 2015 this was right after
you cut your finger off
and right after you told the doctor that
you cut your finger off you were asking
for cocaine and ecstasy that's entirely
possible correct
i'm
not sure that you have the date correct
about when my finger
was
chopped off okay
okay let's let's um let's take a look
i'm pretty sure that the date was the
eighth
now mr depp you remember testifying
well
let's let's put it this way sometimes
these texts um
that the dates of the text messages
you would agree
that um
they're obviously australia's 12 hours
different from this part of the world
correct
or something like that
something like that sure um
so the text the date stamps and time
stamps that are reflected on these texts
may be
reflecting a different time than when
they were actually sent objection
foundation calls for speculation
you agree with that right i'll sustain
the objection okay
um
okay well then let's let's do this so is
it your testimony that
right after you cut your finger off
that you are right after
i won't give you anything to argue with
me yet right after you sustained an
injury to your finger
that's right that you
right after you sustain an injury to
your finger is it your testimony that
you did not
ask for cocaine and ecstasy
right after you told the doctor about
your finger injury
is that your testimony
um
regardless of what date you believe
works
within the world time zone
um
i don't believe that
someone who has gone through
opiate dependency who has lost the
ability
to
to produce dopamine and serotonin in
their own body because
that's what the
opiate does
your body no longer needs to make the
dopamine or the serotonin
the dopamine and serotonin as you know i
imagine
are
things that keep us
[Music]
i appreciate that but my question wasn't
that my question was i'm just trying to
scream you told the doctor about your
finger injury you were asking for coke
it's entirely possible that you were
asking for cocaine and ecstasy objection
yesterday speculation
i'll allow that question answer it
uh
clearly uh need white is more whitey
stuff
um is is is uh
yes it's a reference to cocaine
but that doesn't
uh
there's nothing here that says that i
ingested the drug
not saying there is but you were asking
for more cocaine and you were asking for
more ecstasy correct
i wasn't asking for
more ecstasy i was asking for ecstasy
because that was what i was requested
from was requested by myself let's let's
take a look at the the uk transcript day
three a permission to approach without
your honor okay
day three oh yeah
thank you sir
thank you
i'm sure i couldn't hear you i'm sorry
i'm going to ask you to turn to page 463
and 464 of this please truthfully
are you there
i'm there i'm just reading sorry and on
page 463 line 20
you're asked a question mr depp what i
am asking you about and i think your
barrister mr sherborne agrees the times
we have to factor in it may be we can
put in an agreed local australian time
but what is important do you see is the
order that your finger you have cut your
finger off and straight away after
telling your doctor that you cut your
finger off you are asking for cocaine
and ecstasy
answer yes
that is what it
question that is what it looks like
answer appears to be and it is entirely
possible that i was in the state that i
was in
did i read that right
yes you did
asking for cocaine
so
we talked about the cocaine and the
ecstasy let's talk about the the
the
ultra
argument altercation that you and ms
heard had in australia
um you you you testified that you were
sitting on a bar stool right
in australia this is what are you so
you're fast forwarding to the
the end of the ar uh
of that argument
yeah we've we've heard we've heard your
account of the argument and the jury
will hear miss herds account of the
argument what i want to ask you some
specific questions about you you're
sitting on a bar stool you've had three
or four i think you've said three shots
of vodka i did two or three shots
yes yeah and you're resting with your
hands kind of hanging over the edge like
that right
uh
well after the first bottle
whizzed past my head and shattered
as i said i walked around the bar
grabbed the larger
was another bottle of vodka the only one
there
the larger bottle brought it back
and poured another shot
and did it
and right and and that that was a like a
what we call a handle of vodka is that
right well yeah it's one of the larger
bottles it's got a handle on the right
and it was it was full at the time other
than the shot that you poured
no it wasn't it wasn't a full bottom
okay um and and at some point
before
you you claim you sustained an injury to
your finger you were i believe you
demonstrated to the jury yesterday but
you were resting with your three fingers
um your middle three fingers kind of
hanging over the edge is that is that
fair is that right
uh
[Music]
yes i just had a bottle thrown at me so
i was
when she grabbed the second bottle right
i'm just asking where your fingers were
sir at that point your fingers were your
palm was facing down and your three
middle fingers were hanging over the
edge of the bar correct
basically that's correct um
and
miss
amber was
seven to ten feet away
correct
once she walked yes once you'd grab the
bottle yes okay
and
your testimony and we we've we've heard
it yesterday but your testimony is that
somehow she wound up with this handle of
vodka and and threw it and it it it uh
damaged part of your middle finger but
what we didn't talk about and what i
want to ask you about is it didn't
if it happened the way you said it
didn't didn't damage any other part of
your hand correct no other part of your
fingers no none of the other middle
fingers that were hanging over the edge
of the bar were injured connection
compound
we can take it piece by piece
none of the none of the three fingers
that were hanging over the edge of the
bar were sustained to any injury other
than your middle finger is
correct
um
the
middle finger certainly took the brunt
of it as the tip
and there's
cut off there's no there's no record of
any glass being found in that middle
finger
correct
objection calls for speculation i'm i'm
i'll allow if you can answer it
um
i'm i'm i'm
not a doctor and i'm not sure what
was uh
found in the middle finger or what i do
know is that when i went to the
emergency room that they
and they had to um
inject me with a block to be able to put
it into
a bucket and
take a wire brush to to scrub it um all
clean
because i had
all the makeup still left from pirates
on there and
makeup from pirates okay we'll get to
that in a second but
neither none of the other fingers on
your hand were sustained any injury that
you're aware of correct
uh
no there were
nothing else was separate okay and in
fact it wasn't just makeup from pirates
that was on your hand it was paint that
you would dip your middle finger into to
write along with blood to write on
mirrors and lamps and
assorted
furniture in the house correct objection
compound
all right i'll sustain is the compound
there was it wasn't just makeup you
testified yesterday that it was just
makeup from the side of pirates 5 but in
fact after you sustained an injury to
your finger you dipped it in paint in
the house and you wrote in paint mixed
with blood all over the place objection
compound i'll sustain the objection
you dipped your finger in paint in the
house and wrote on objects in the house
objection compound
that sustained objections you dipped
your finger in paint after suffering an
injury
yes
and then you use that finger
to write on objects in the house
yes or no
yes that was after i'd um
after writing on the walls of the blood
had kind of
dried as it were and or
and so i
uh
stuck my finger in to a can of paint and
also
excuse me mineral spirits
to um
to
put my verbal messages onto the wall and
you use your you use your finger as a
paintbrush right
essentially yes
and
can we put up exhibit 369 please
um
it might you know it might be plaintiffs
let's
um
now mr depp we're going to we're going
to take a a look at some pictures
shortly but
you'd agree with me that there was quite
a bit of damage to the house in
australia after this incident correct
um there was
there was quite a bit of damage to the
house
[Music]
during the
um the entire incident yeah and you
don't remember the television breaking
do you
i remember there was a
i believe there was a coffee cup stuck
into the screen or a plate or something
like that you don't remember the window
breaking do you
i don't remember window breaking but you
do remember that there was quite a lot
of blood everywhere including on floors
and sofas
well i've noticed that's how i'd noticed
that i was
leaking
there was heat in my finger and it was
i felt this warmth and this liquid and
then
i noticed that the tip of my finger was
gone
and at that point i think i went into
some sort of
shock or whatever is closest to a
kind of nervous breakdown yeah you
testify that
breakdown it's you you could have um
also
defaced a painting
by drawing a penis on it didn't you
i've never
i don't know about that i don't remember
trying to see us on a painting given the
state you were in it's entirely possible
that you did that even if you don't
remember it to this day correct
drawing a penis on a painting was not
the first thing on my mind
let's add messages
to uh
write reminders
that were from his heard but you don't
deny that
if a painting was the face with a penis
drawn on it that that could have been
you even if you were blacked out and
don't remember that correct objection
speculation
this was no blackout i know you loved
the word it was no blackout
it was
shock
that wasn't my question mr depp
respectfully it was you don't deny that
you could have defaced the painting in
the manner that i just described
well given
given that i
had written some messages on the
bathroom mirror and then misheard
added to them
it's also not impossible that miss heard
may have
drawn a penis on a
painting somewhere
i i
that's not where i was going
let's take a look at page 451 of your
testimony in the uk trial please
yes sir
and if you look at page
451
line 21 please
you were asked the question let me ask
you is defacing a painting something
that you are likely to have forgotten
answer i recall a painting on a
lampshade
on a wall
on a mirror i remember dunking my finger
into paint thinner and using paint when
i had run out of blood to paint with and
i could have defaced the painting i
suppose but i do not remember a painting
specifically
question down below on 452 line 15
so there are parts of this episode that
you do not remember at all because that
would be quite a big thing would it not
painting a penis on a picture
answer it would be quite a big thing i
do not recall
question it is not something you would
do by accident is it do you do
you do not accidentally
answer no i would say not
question you have no recollection answer
i am sorry i'm not 100 sure that i can
say i did that
did i read that right
you did read it right sir thank you
let's take a look at um exhibit 374
please
is it defendants exhibit 374 yes your
honor okay
mr deb do you recognize this as one of
the mirrors that you wrote on uh with
your injured finger
in march of 2015.
uh yes i do
and
yesterday you texted
you texted i'm sorry
we've seen a lot of texts today that's
all right i did take someone yesterday
yesterday
you testified that
you wrote on the mirror and i don't i
don't remember exactly what you said but
you essentially said that you wrote uh
things about your past with misheard or
or grievances that you had with her
correct yes okay um you're on our
permission to uh move or move this in as
an exhibit and ask for permission to
publish any objection no objection 374
in evidence
you can publish
you could just blow that up a little bit
is it possible
so
on this which you you wrote on with your
severed finger
you wrote
in some some mix of paint or blood
starring
billy bob
and
easy amber
yes sir
miss heard arrived directly in australia
from filming the film london fields in
england
with billy bob thornton correct
that's correct
and you hadn't seen
your new bride in three or four weeks
and she arrives
you're not happy about her filming with
billy bob thornton and so as part of
this
altercation
incident
after
your finger is injured you write
starring billy bob and easy amber on the
mirror correct objection compound i'll
sustain the objection
i'll move on okay
let's pull up exhibit 375 please
don't
this is mr deputy recognize this as
another
mirror on which you wrote with your in
blood and paint uh after your finger
injury in march of 2015. yes sir that's
in the same
bathroom
okay
you're on a
move for admission of exhibit 375 and
request permission to publish no
objection 375 in evidence published
okay
can we please
pull up
exhibit 377
please
mr depp
this is a picture of a lampshade that
you wrote on
after you sustained a finger injury on
march 8 2015. correct that's correct
you're on our move for admission of
exhibit 377
no objection all right 377 in evidence
you can publish permission to publish
and
on this lampshade
which appears to be sitting on the
ground
you write
some mixture of blood or paint
good luck and be careful at top
yes correct correct
yes
i thought it was good advice
now
you have never
and i know miss heard will give her
account of this
of this incident later in the trial
just to be clear you have never seen
amber inflict harm on herself or on her
arms or anything like that correct
objection compound
sustain you've never seen amber inflict
harm on herself
that depends on your definition of harm
sir
i i
that's quite a broad word
can you please pull up your uk testimony
at page
434
objection your honor baby we approach
yes
mr depp are you um are you there on page
434 line 25
for the 434 okay yes
and uh in the uk trial where you asked
this question and did you give this
answer question you have never seen her
inflict harm on herself on her arms or
anything like that during the time you
were with her answer no no
did i read that right
i don't
see it on
page 434
can you go to the top of page 435 so
sorry if i wasn't clear let's go 435
okay yeah so the bottom of page 34
question you have never seen her inflict
harm on herself on her arms or anything
like that
during the time you were with her and
then the answer at the top of page 435
is no no
i read that correctly
you did thank you
um
now
you testified yesterday that when you
went to the hospital that you told them
um that you had
uh injured your finger in an accordion
door remember giving that testimony
yes i do
that's
actually not true is it you you actually
told the hospital uh that you would cut
it off with a kitchen knife
isn't that right no that's not true okay
can you pop exhibit 360 please i believe
there was
uh one of my team who might have said
that to the doctor but that was not my
um those are not my words
at any rate we were looking to keep
amber's name out of it
[Music]
mr depp i'm not going to move this
exhibit into evidence but
do you see the the portion
um where it says thanks for seeing and
treating this patient you see that and
then right after that it said he
sustained an injury to his right middle
finger tonight after accidentally
cutting it with a kitchen knife
you see that i do see that there's no
mention of an accordion door in that
document is there
i'll read it if you like but uh
that was the
i didn't sign my name to this
and that's not my statement to them i
use the accordion door you testified
yesterday
i can't help that
you testified yesterday that you told dr
kipper
that miss heard had in fact been
responsible for your finger injury do
you remember giving that testimony yes
but in fact
in subsequent communications adopt dr
kipper you reference more than once that
you chopped off your own finger to dr
kipper correct
i think the key word is chopped off my
own finger
um when you say to someone i've ch i've
chopped my finger off
um
that's just going straight to the
fact
you don't get into
um
she did this i did that this
my finger
my fingers been chopped off
let's take a look at exhibit 398 please
i'd like to direct your attention sir to
the text message number 94
which is a text message from you to dr
david kipper on march 19 2015.
do you see that um
a wheel in a second
sure
94
uh
this is uh yes march 19th so i was in
los angeles yes
yes i i see the
i see the text your honor i would move
for the admission of this exhibit with
just that text uh displayed and every
identifier redacted
no objection your honor all right if we
could do that redactions thank you ron
it was a pathetic attempted humor my
apologies
all right 398 and evidence has redacted
just blow that up if you can a little
bit more
thank you so in this text message from
you to dr kipper on march 19 2015
you text him my most sincere apologies
to you doc
i understand your decision based on my
immunity to do the right thing and i
truly do thank you for your concern
i must apologize for not having had the
presence of mind to respect the man who
has been the most kind and who has done
more for me than anyone ever
there was no call for my spineless and
base behavior toward you
i honestly understand the reasons for
your concerns in your letter and can say
to you now they no longer are an issue
thank you for everything
i have chopped off
my left middle finger
as a reminder
that i should never cut my finger off
again
i love you brother
johnny
did i read that right
you did and miss heard was not on that
text message was she no she was no
uh can you take that down and put up uh
exhibit 499 please
all right
and i'd like to
like to direct direct your attention to
item 39
um
second text down
which is a text message exchange between
you and aaron borham dr kipper's nurse
on october 31st 2015. you see that
yes i did
your honor i'd move for admission of
this exhibit with just that text message
no objection all right i hope we get
redacted in the appropriate redactions
thank you
all right 499 evidence with the
redactions
and in this text message
from you to dr kipper's nurse aaron
borum in october of 2015
you say and i'll just try to read the
relevant part sent huge texts to kipper
no response
he's an odd duck old kipper
this is the second time that he's held
off giving me meds by blackmailing me
into seeing him
the first time i had just chopped my
finger off
hmm
oh well i want off of the majority of
the stuff anyway i guess that's a new
way to stop x
did i read that right
you did so and amber is not on that text
exchange correct no she's not okay
i'd like to um if we can pull up uh
exhibit
343
i believe it's plaintiff's exhibit 343
and this is this is where you tell amber
in a recording
that
you mentioned the day i chopped my
finger off so let's listen to that
are you entering a 343 into evidence
yeah i think it's plain it's it's it's
the same one that was played yesterday i
believe that was plaintiffs 343.
343 already in evidence and just for the
record which portions are you playing
sure
okay
which portion are you playing i'm
playing um
202
15
to 202 19.
is that right
i don't know if we'll be able to get it
exactly right so there's a second or two
on either side but we'll do our best
that's fine
do we have the date of this recording
mr uh
gotten one
what's the date of the recording i'm
sorry i don't know it's a plaintiff's
exhibit i'm not i don't know the date of
the recording okay
[Music]
you hear that you said the day i chopped
my finger off
let's let's play it again that'd be
great thank you
fight you're talking about i don't know
i'm talking about australia today though
now we're talking about australia okay
are you sure that
yeah let's do it one more time
was it the day that i got my finger
chopped off no no you say the day that i
chopped my finger off so let's play it
one more time because i think i left out
the word that it says the day that i
chopped my finger off
i'm talking about australia today though
now we're talking about australia okay
i'm not sure in fact earlier you had
quoted jerry judge from uh
the airplane tape is calling me an
[ __ ]
wait till the [ __ ] falls asleep
and i'm positive
that those words never
left his
mouth because he was
he would have
if i would have been making those noises
in the bathroom he would have ripped the
hinges off
maybe they left his mouth when you were
passed out sir respectfully
let's listen to this one more times
sustain is argumentative i'll move to
strike all right next question
you know i just want to play this video
this one more time
please i'm talking about australia today
though we're talking about australia
okay
yeah we can move on let's bring up
exhibit
380.
please 380.
this is another recording your honor um
i don't know whether it's been admitted
into evidence yet 380
plaintiffs 380
or defendants 380.
i
believe it's defendants
i left my cheat sheet
okay i
thought it was an easy question i'm
sorry and it's okay
i had it written down and all right in
front of me
yes
all right i don't know if that's in
evidence or not is it plain 380 in
evidence no
so you're offering 380 before we hear it
can we put it in evidence yes your honor
move move it into evidence and the the
portions that i'd like to play are
um
33 33
through 34 10.
i assume no objections this is the audio
but as long as this is a audio recording
of just mr depp and miss hurt we have no
objection this portion is this portion
is yes i believe that there's other
portions that involve other people but
as best i'm aware
um
well actually
actually no may we approach because i
think
all right ladies and gentlemen they're
going to work out an issue with one of
the
video
the audio recording so we'll go ahead
and take our 15 minute recess for the
afternoon okay do not discuss the case
and you're not doing the outside
research okay
all right okay
okay sure
thank you
thank you
all right thank you be seated in your
next question sir
thank you your honor i i think before
the break um
we were going to ask to play a portion
of exhibit 380 which is an audio
recording
counsel for both sides have conferred
that
neither side has an objection to the
following excerpt being played which is
33 33
through 34
minutes through 3400. so 33 minutes to
34 minutes so you're only entering to
evidence that one minute of this audio
is that correct yes you're on our office
so somebody's going to get me
an audio clip of just that at some point
correct sure we're happy to take care of
that okay so i'll make that 380a
we can fight over the rest of it later
but for now this will be just plain 380
a plaintiff's 380a would you like we're
happy to take care of that if let's find
somebody just gives me that one minute
oh it's i'm told it's actually
defendants so
oh they're both 380 so
take your pick so we'll get it to you
how about that oh joy okay
all right three three somebody's we're
going to go with planers 380 right now
okay
try to keep the record clear 380a and 33
234 okay go
are and ahead you are and how do you
[ __ ] me over
and make me feel sick
of myself
[Music]
that's your voice in that audio
recording mr depp correct it is indeed
now um we we talked a little bit about
what you wrote on on the one mirror when
you said billy bob thornton and easy
amber
remember seeing that picture a few
minutes ago i do and we talked about how
amber had just been in london filming a
film with billy bob thornton correct
that's correct now when when you were
apart
from her she would want to socialize
with other people and that made you feel
insecure right
and speculative compound sustain is the
compound when you were apart she would
want to socialize with other people
right
yes i suppose at times yes and that
occasionally made you feel insecure
didn't it
not
necessarily no
let's let's look at page 257 of your uk
transcript please i think that's day two
day two
three
thirty what was the number again i'm
sorry sure no problem it's day two of
page 257 250
so it's page 23 of the document
so
two five seven
yes sir two five seven line thirteen
um
did you give the following testimony in
response to the following questions
question
and when you were apart she would want
to do things with other people see other
people go out with other people
socialize yes
answer yes sure
question
and did this occasionally make you feel
insecure
answer occasionally yes it did
did i read that right
you did
can we please pull up um
plaintiffs exhibit 343 which is a
recording
it's been
admitted and we propose to play
seconds 30 through 45.
with your permission your honor may we
go ahead and play that portion
um
[Music]
when you're doing movies i become
jealous and [ __ ] crazy and weird and
you know we fight
a lot more
can we play that one more time please
actually before we do so
this is you tell her you become
irrational when you're doing movies
um
and you just you say you become
become weird you heard those right
let's just let's do it yeah let's play
it again thank you
very
[Music]
doing movies i much
jealous and [ __ ] crazy and weird and
you know we fight
a lot
so
you heard yourself mr depp say i become
a rational when you're we're doing
movies you heard that right
we're i can play it again if you like
it's it's very it's very difficult to to
tell if that's a you or i
sure why don't we play it again thank
you
when you're doing movies i become
jealous and [ __ ] crazy and weird and
you know we fight
a lot more
mr dev in that in that audio you say i
become irrational when you're doing
movies i become jealous [ __ ] crazy
and weird and we fight a lot more you
heard that right
he has something in that effect yeah you
can take that down
i'd like to fast forward
mr depp to
december 15 2015.
i know there's been some testimony on
that day
for the jury
and
you and miss heard
you gave some testimony yesterday about
an
altercation that you had that evening do
you remember giving that testimony
um
yes okay and do you remember this
evening i'm not sure
yeah and okay um and
um
you would agree that after
this altercation
that uh that you had that you wrote
in on the countertop
in
your um your penthouse at the ecb
in like a gold sharpie remember that
very well yes
and
your your um
okay your council has
shown a picture to you that allegedly
was taken that day i'd like to pull up
um plaintiffs exhibit 409 which was
shown to the witness yesterday i believe
your honor
that's plain as four now i'm sorry in
evidence so we'll go ahead and publish
it um is there a sarah
it's it's the yeah there we go
um
mr depp um
and
the jury will see
um
hear more about this as the case goes on
but do you recognize this picture of
misheard as a picture that was taken
directly after the december 15 2015
incident
i don't know when it was
i don't know when the photograph was
taken i don't know
much about it okay how was that we could
take that down
in any event you
you don't disagree that um that there
was a headbutt that evening that i know
that there's disagreement about the
cause of it but you you would agree that
um that you headbutted misheard that
evening correct
no i would vehemently disagree with that
sir
there was a lot of
i was trying to restrain this is her
misheard um and
in the
once i had
restrained her
um it's i would say if she's trying to
still
move around and kick at me or trying to
get loose
any sort of movement when you're like
this and your heads are
together this close together
it's not impossible for for um
for them to bump but a headbutt a
headbutt is uh
that's pretty extreme okay let's let's
definition of that let's let's take a
listen to um exhibit 587
um
i believe that's defendants exhibit 587
and your honor i'd this is this is one
of the recordings that
is just
just just uh the two parties um
amber and mr depp and we would play
proposed to play
8 45 through 9 20. all right is is this
whole 587 coming into evidence the whole
tape or just that portion yes we propose
the whole tape come in and to the extent
that the tape is all just the two parts
and that's just the two parties in this
tape i believe so your honor we i
believe yes
i mean
we can we will confirm but for right now
i'd just like to get
this part in evidence if we can if we
can have tonight we'll confirm with you
tomorrow that the whole thing is just
the two of them that's my understanding
all right well so right now i can only
put 587 a in which and the minutes are
what were the minutes again
8 45 to 9 20. 8 45 to 9 20. okay that
that portion's in evidence at the moment
okay
what you did
yeah thanks for your song he's happy
screaming
[Music]
but don't scream
[Music]
that doesn't break
i don't know
don't we play that one more time please
because mr jeff
my question for you is did you say i
head-butted you in the forehead that
doesn't break a nose so let's take
another listen excuse me
somehow
the end all because
sort of offensive thing you can throw a
punch at you screaming it's okay you can
headbutt somebody screaming but don't
scream
mr deputy said i headbutted you in the
[ __ ] forehead that doesn't break a
nose um correct
i did i did say those words but i didn't
i said i
i
was using the words that ms heard was
using okay um
but there was not an intentional
headbutt
and if you want to have a peaceful
conversation with miss heard
you might have to placate just a little
bit okay
let's let's listen to um exhibit 598
please your honor this is another
um
this is another recording that
i believe is just between the two i just
want to confirm with my team but for now
um we just asked to it to play
um
minutes
605 through 7 36
of 598. 598 a an evidence of 605 to 736.
thank you your honor
whose loudest is most responsible my 16
year old daughter heard you just saying
she would rather not hear me i'd wait
because i'm louder
by the way my family my friends everyone
around me
had saw all the bruises and
broken a broken blood vessel under my
eye the bruises on my head the missing
chunks of hair the split lip the black
eye the swollen nose all that [ __ ]
because you're stronger it does not mean
it does not mean because they heard me
that i'm somehow more responsible it
just means they hurt me because i yell
in a fight you do provoke i yell it
doesn't mean i'm more responsible or
badder
however i am exposed via that the
distance of between cafe cabrones in the
house is significant and i know
i know
that that does not mean that they got an
accurate representation of our fight but
if you told them stuff great cool thanks
for exposing me as i said to you before
don't do it again unless you want me to
really
also tell them my side of things because
trust me you know
trust me you know i have a different
type than you and if i show them
pictures and stuff i'm sure they'll have
even more different side and in fact if
i told them even more stuff to have the
even more clear picture of what i think
on both sides maybe i should show off
maybe i should show them this
that's true
the mineral spirits do whatever you want
you can do it
you can do it by the way do it i promise
you do it do whatever you don't want me
to do no you owe it
to you again you do whatever you want
let's take a look at defendants exhibit
526 please
after the incident on december 15th
you wrote these words on the countertop
at suites or at ecb the eastern columbia
building correct
and that is correct
and that's your handwriting on the
counter right you wrote i wrote in my
own handwriting yes sir why be a fraud
all is such [ __ ]
you see that very well yes and that's in
penthouse three i meant it
okay
why be a fraud
okay why lie
well let's let's take a look at this
let's take a look at uh exhibit 580.
mr depp i'd like to direct your
attention to the text message two up
from the bottom um it's a text message
uh this is my question to you it's a
text message from you to david heard
amber's father on december 30th 2015. do
you see that it's
it's good question 131 can you scroll
and and my only question for you now is
that's a text message from you to david
hurd on december 30th 2015.
correct
um i was just reading it sir
sorry
yes
yes that's
from me to david hurt you're on our move
for admission of 580
just that text is all i want to ask the
witness about
no objection but with the redactions of
the phone numbers of course
okay
580 entered in evidence with redactions
thank your honor
so in this text message mr depp that you
sent on december 30th
2015
you tell him
amber's father
below is a text that i never hit send on
from a week or so again
it was in response to you
hey brother
i love you too
more than you can ever imagine
it's rare in life when one meets a
kindred spirit a couple of mad men with
their thirst for further
there have only been maybe three people
in my entire life of your ilk you're a
rare specimen and our friendship means
everything
yes i [ __ ] up
and went too far in our fight
i cannot and will not excuse my part
inside these dramas
but i can promise you with all
confidence they will never happen again
my most sincere apologies if i've let
you down love you brother
did i read that right
you did read that man yes and so
in this text sent on december 30th
you're telling david heard that you
messed up and went too far
in a fight
it doesn't say a physical
fight and an audio fight can be
arguments sure and in the audio that we
just heard
amber's talking to you about people
seeing her injuries
from december 15 and how she hid them
from your kids during christmas
objection hearsay is that right i'll
just listen to this i know i'll sustain
the objection to that question next
question okay
after you came back from
australia
um you and amber saw you can take that
down
you and amber saw uh
someone by the name of dr amy banks
you you joined her by skype do you
remember that
uh the only time that i've ever seen any
dr amy banks was on a
a
a video link from australia
right and you saw her individual you saw
her for a joint session with amber
correct
yes and then you saw her individually
for a session as well do you recall that
yes a brief brief session as far as i
remember yeah and during during the
joint session with dr banks you didn't
contradict amber's reporting that you
were violent correct all right if he if
he did if he contradicted that i'll
sustain the objection next question
we're going to jump around a little bit
in time here mr depp
earlier today you recall
[Music]
that we we talked about march of 2013
and we showed you saw the picture with
the the cocaine box that said property
of jd you remember that oh yes yes um
i'd like to show you
a few documents here
michelle can can you pull up exhibit
defendants exhibit 159 please 159.
and
mr depp what i'm going to ask you about
is
is the second text down
it's the text
um from you to
someone named sis who i think you
testified was um
he said at first it was christy but i
think he then testified that it was
whitney heard correct
sis is always
whitney um
i call my sister christy something else
another nickname okay
um
your honor i'd move for the and well
this is a text from you to
whitney on march 9th 2013. correct
you see that
what am i supposed to see i'm sorry the
the second uh that the text uh sec two
down is a text from you to whitney dated
march 9th 2013.
yes i see that yes okay yes sir um
your honor i would move for the
admission of this exhibit 159 with that
text and then the second and third text
from the bottom
please
with the appropriate redactions on
everything else
may we approach your honor
okay
can you
michelle can you please redact
everything but the second text message
please
all right
and what we'll do we'll just call this
159 a should be admitted with redactions
okay thank you honor all right thank you
so mr deb yeah this is a text message
you sent to whitney heard on march 9
2013
and in this text message
you say
you blow that up as as best you can
please
we had a slightly grim morning
but not a doozy
we kissed she splits and texts me
sweet
stuff
i do the same right back and nada so i
just want to know that she is safe i've
heard nothing just worried about her xxx
jd
did i read that right
yes okay so that text
was sent on march 9 2013
with that in mind could you please pull
up defendants exhibit 161.
um can you scroll uh yeah no here we go
do you see
four texts or five texts up from the
bottom there's a text exchange between
you
and miss heard
you see that
yes i do
and
this is sent on march 12 2013.
okay yes sir
which if i'm doing my my calculation
right
was tuesday march 12 2013
and in the top text you write
just thought you should know that there
exists a book titled disco bloodbath
that's all
you see that did i read that right yes
you did
your honor i'd move to um move for the
admission of
this exhibit with those texts
when you say those texts which ones just
uh those four
the taxi change between mr depp and miss
heard okay any objection to that
we have no objection to the admission of
the four text messages between mr depp
and miss hurt on that day make those
redactions
[Music]
all right 161 in evidence
with the redactions you can publish
thank you your honor
so
we'll just focus on the text
so we can see the top text is from you
to misheard
um and you say just thought you should
know that there exists a book titled
disco bloodbath that's all
and amber wrote you back and said we
need that book exclamation point
and you wrote back and said
is it about last friday night
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i got it
wrong
amber writes you and says we need that
book
and then she writes you and says
is it about last friday night by any
chance
and you write
how can you make me smile about such a
hideous moment
yes it is
funny [ __ ]
i [ __ ] love you you [ __ ]
you wrote that on tuesday march 12th
2013
referring to
the previous friday night
march 8th 2013. correct
i believe that um this subject
i sent her that text
that there exists a book called disco
bloodbath
from a bookstore that i was in
she said we need the book um asked me
about if it was about last friday i
believe that i have a very different
opinion of what that friday was than
you do and i
well you your your counsel can ask you
about that and and
i think that's when we'll get into that
um
but my question to you is you are you're
writing when you're referring to such a
hideous moment you're responding to miss
herd's text is about is is it about last
friday night by any chance
isn't that right
that's what she's asking me okay
um
you can take that down please
[ __ ]
can you please bring up defendants
exhibit 638
[Music]
i'm all right what what is
i'm going to enter this into evidence
sir yes your honor move for the
admission of this video into evidence
we have no objection your honor all
right 638 in evidence thank you now you
can publish
[Music]
what happened
what happened
[Music]
nothing happened this morning you know
that
were you in here
no
nothing happened to you this morning
yeah you're right i just woke up and you
were so sweet and nice
we were not even fighting this morning
all i did was say sorry did something
happen
to you
this morning
i don't think so
um
no that's the thing you want to see
crazy i'll give you [ __ ] crazy
oh you're crazy
are you crazy have you drunk this whole
thing this morning oh you got this guy
you got this going
oh really
really
[Music]
see that [ __ ] on me
[ __ ]
[Music]
do we have a date for this um
since you have some questions about it
let's why don't we watch it again
again
okay we you know what we can we don't
have to do that that's good we don't
have to do that
this is at your house in west hollywood
on sweets or avenue correct that's
correct
and that's you in the video mr depp
right
that's correct
and you would agree
that
you were violent in that clip correct
um
clearly i was having a bad
time
i don't uh i don't know what it was with
regard to completely at this point since
i don't know the date but um
um
being illegally recorded by
your
chosen other is
uh
well it's quite fitting with the rest of
the photographs and
tape recordings she made so um
i thought what was most interesting is
that she
tried to hide it from me and then that
she
laughed
and smiled at the end
i thought that was most interesting part
myself but so yes
i did assault um
a couple of cabinets but i did not touch
miss hurt
as you can see i think no
and you may have been
you may have been
may have been drunk in that video
correct
there's a possibility of that yes sir
you you poured yourself a
um a mega pint of red wine correct
a mega pint
yeah
i poured myself a large glass of wine
right i thought it necessary right right
well
let's look at let's look at uk 101
please
101
yeah this is day one
you see um see there at line five do you
have the page up i i don't see 101 yet
okay sorry take your time i've got a
i've got a bit of a bushel here
sorry
it's it's on the it's in the volume for
day one
if that helps yes yeah that's what i'm
looking through but it's all um
it's a bit of a jumble oh oh sorry
page 101 is that what you'd like yes sir
and
just
since you you seemed amused by the
terminology um you were asked the
question question you were drunk i'm
going to suggest what do you say to that
answer i may have been where are we sir
uh line five thank you question you were
drunk i'm going to suggest what do you
say to that answer i may have been i do
not recall the chances are very good
that if that i was if i was upset
question we saw you pour a sort of
answer mega pint
question mega pine of red wine which is
not everybody's choice for breakfast is
it
answer no did i read that right
you did
and you were very very upset in that
video correct
i think that's pretty clear yes and and
you would agree that your behavior in
that clip could be intimidating to
anyone present in that room correct
objection calls for speculation i'll
sustain the objection okay you would
agree that you uh your your behavior was
intimidating correct objection calls for
speculation all right i'll sustain the
objection okay
now you're a lot bigger than amber
correct
physically
i wouldn't say that
yeah um
the stan i would would you agree with me
that that um the standards of a southern
gentleman were not in your mind in this
particular moment were they
um i i don't know about anyone else but
i have had experiences in my life where
um one does
stray
uh from
uh
from complete
control over their
uh emotions
at times and um
and that
is a
very normal
primal
thing to do
i did not
try to intimidate miss heard if she was
intimidated
why was she filming if she was scared to
death why didn't she leave
can you pull up exhibit 821 please
defendants exhibit
we're going to fast forward in time a
little bit mr depp um yes i can feel it
i
i'd like to direct your attention to
uh the
third text down
to text message from you
to your sister
on june 4th 2016. yes sir you see that
objection relevance your honor
all right what's the rule
can you pull up exhibit 870 please
actually um can you pull up uh it's
plaintiff's exhibit 157
11.
150 157 page 11. there we go okay 157
plaintiffs 157 yes your honor
mr depp um
these are text messages that you sent to
uh your friend isaac baroosh
correct
yes and i'll i'll just say that i'm not
proud of any of the language that i've
used in these
anger
uh
you're on our move for admission of just
this page or this exhibit
um your honor we object on relevance
all right if you want to approach
all right with the uh reserved actions
you can tell what reactions you're doing
sure just those middle two texts please
all right plane is 157 page 11 so i
guess 157 a
page 11
in with red actions needed
you're on our permission to publish this
redacted exhibit all right yes sir
mr deb these are two texts that you sent
to
isaac baroosh
the jury is heard from on
october 17 2016 and october 18 2016.
can can you just read for the jury your
that first text
you'd like me to read then yes please
sure mr rottenborn
is the slippery [ __ ]
that i donated my jizz to for a while
staying there and can you please read
the text under that please certainly
i'm not sure i sent that text though
well i'll i'll read it you say no i'll
read it it's fine if you don't have to
hear that yeah you know i'll go ahead
and read it
you you tell mr baruch on october 18
2016
hopefully
that cunt's rotting corpse is
decomposing in the [ __ ] trunk of a
honda civic two exclamation points did i
read that right
you did
you can you can take that down michelle
please
and can you please
can you please pull up
exhibit
four eight five
defendants
exhibit four eight five
um
do you recognize this as a text exchange
that you had between you and amber heard
on september 28 2015.
yes sir
for the admission of uh the exhibit with
just um happy to
happy to have all of it or just mr
depp's depending on what his council
wants
give him a moment to read it of course
uh we're happy to have the um mr depp
and mrs heard's portions admitted but we
would ask that the phone numbers be
redacted all right of course so
we could redact
the identifying
information
all right 485 and evidence as redacted
can you can you blow up the top text
michelle please
and i'm not going gonna read the whole
text mr depp but
um
if you if you start um
four lines down you say and i'm on such
a beastly head [ __ ] from earlier that i
feel like i won't know what to do or how
to be
i feel like i only just continue to piss
you off believe me i never want to hurt
you and always have never wanted to hurt
you never i don't want to be in that
position anymore not ever again i feel
pushed and i push back
i feel hurt
i will hurt back
a fight commences i will fight back and
obviously so will you
but i can't again to see it coming it
puts us both in some stubborn space
where neither of us can hear much less
understand one another's position
do i read that right
you did so can we pull up exhibit 186
please may i just make a point of
clarification for dx 485 it's a
multi-page exhibit oh is it okay i just
want to make sure it's just this page it
was yeah that it was just that page all
right what page is it
page one one of eight so that'll be 485
a page one okay thank you thank you
thank you miss myers
186.
one piece
mr depp
um if you can go to the the first page
michelle please
um this is a text exchange between you
and miss heard
on september 6 2013 correct
on
what's the date
september 6 2013 i believe you see that
in the lower right of the text boxes
third
well from the second one
the top one says
september 5th starts on the fifth right
and then i was looking at the one that
starts thank you for your letter
that's september 6th correct that is
september 16th okay um
and then if you if you
your honor i'd move for admission of
this document starting with the text
that says thank you for your letter
um
and
happy to have both texts or not
depending on what mr depp's counsel
argues but
thank you for your letter and then going
into the next page
through the
text that says i have other uses
could we please scroll down just to see
a little further
can you scroll down a little bit further
thank you
can we please continue down further
i think we would like through
the text messages on the third page um
through mr depp's text at
september 6 2013 at 8 10
a.m
no objection to that that's fine all
right so it's
so it's exhibit defend exhibit 186 pages
one through three then as redacted is
that correct
yes your honor so 186 a
pages one through three as
redacted okay
um
[Music]
can you just scroll down so
council can see and the court can see if
the redactions are right
all right looks correct all right
entered in evidence then 186a all right
permission to publish yes
if you
can yeah there we go um
so mr depp on september 6 2013
you
send miss
heard a text that says thank you for
your letter i love you
yes scroll down
she writes thank you for mine i read
that right
you did and then you write
the only reason we go for the throat is
love
did i read that right you did
and then she writes
my throat is yours
you're going to be the death of me
but i don't care
and then you write
i have other uses for your throat which
do not include
injury
i have other uses for your throat
which do not include injury
sorry could you read that again
do your words sir right i read that
right correct
you did okay
you can take that down
can you pull up exhibit 483 please
this is a journal
that you
uh that you and and amber would write to
each other in correct
it's a picture of a journal right
that's correct
and this is an entry that you made on
september
looks like september 27 2015. is that
right
that's correct
and if uh your honor i'd move for is
there another page below it
okay i'd move for the admission of these
two pages uh as exhibit
two
sorry 483a
any objection no objection all right 43
and that's the first and second page of
that exhibit correct yes your honor okay
one and two okay
all right in evidence you can
you can permission to publish publish
and if you can scroll down michelle to
the bottom that starts with i love and
adore you
please
mr depp you write in this journal and
and just to be clear this journal is
something that you and amber would write
notes to each other in that the other
one would would be supposed to read
correct
yes we wrote notes to each other for the
each other to read and you wrote i love
and adore you i can't express how sorry
i am
for having stooped so low
as to have spewed such vicious untruths
for the sole purpose
of hurting you
i am far from being proud of myself for
such a
next page
grievous error
shameful
i will never allow myself to resort to
such disgraceful
and odious behavior
no matter what did i read that right
you did
can you please pull up
audio tape 396
please
has that already been entered in
evidence
396.6 is it is it plaintiffs or
defendants exhibit sorry
i'm told we think it's plaintiff's
exhibit
56 is it 396. has it been an evidence no
396 plaintiffs
and this is another one of those your
honor that i'm i'm pretty sure it's just
between the two but i'd like to confirm
396a which part are you playing
709 to 719
and 2004 to 2023
and this is just
two
two clips
yes your honor any objection to those
two clips
no your honor all right 396 a entered
into evidence
i'm not your [ __ ] i [ __ ] hate you
i [ __ ] hate you i don't wanna [ __ ]
this come on
come on
in that portion of the recording uh mr
deb you tell
amber you're a [ __ ] and you [ __ ] hate
her correct
yes i did okay
can we play the next portion please
ah
so the first clip was at seven about
seven minutes in this is at 20 minutes
in so that was about 13 minutes later
correct
my maths right
i i
i don't know what's the date
can you pull up that time that you don't
have date can you pull up exhibit 180
please
defendants 180
yes
[Music]
you scroll down please
i believe you've you've testified um mr
jeff you you did not like miss heard
um
expressing her disapproval of your
drinking and drug habits correct
that you
just got through went far
further much further than just uh drink
and
substances okay let's let's go to the
first page of this please
this is uh text messages
from you to miss heard
on
looks like july 19th
or sorry july 9th 2013. do you see that
yes
okay
and is it just two pages
okay
three um your honor i'd move for the
admission of defendants exhibit 180.
any objection or you need to look at the
three pages
if yeah i think we saw the first two
could we just see the third sure
okay yeah that's fine all right you know
objection 180 and evidence with the is
there any redactions needed
um i don't believe so no identifier i
don't it doesn't appear to be okay it's
our lucky day all right there you go all
right 180 and evidence then you can
publish okay
uh
in this and and when it says steve here
uh mr jeff that's that's
what miss heard referred to you as
correct
yes and you were you referred to her as
slim right yeah yes that's correct and
and so you text her
rears uh
tears beers shears sapphires lears jeers
queers
here's
fock ears mouseketeers ears i can go all
night dj maxipad the old vintage
[ __ ] you went for dumbass
sorry i was signing off as a dumbass and
then below that you write don't call me
again and do not expect anything from me
do you see that
i do see that i read that right
you really did let's go to the next page
please
eat salad
with your equine
a.d bovine europes
and thanks for the support have a great
shoot
you sicken me
leave me [ __ ] be officer squarehead
your display of guilt and matronlyness
as a lesbian camp counselor was plenty
your future is on display
best of luck
best if look
thank you for the correction best if
luck and thanks for the tunes bye jd
don't call again i will begin to feel
embarrassed for you go away coach
hup
done did i read that right
no
slowly coach
done
hop
done
thank you otherwise did i read that
right
um
sure you agree that referring to amber's
a lesbian camp counselor is a highly
offensive
reference to make correct
um
what's the date here 2013 it wasn't um
as
considered as egregious um there was a
bit more
there was a bit more um
understanding about
terms amber also called herself a
lesbian camp counselor many times
so
um
i don't think i'm the first to say that
you'd agree that
there's nothing appropriate about
referring to
your
girlfriend or fiance is that
in those disparaging terms in that text
correct objection compound
all right sustain income you'd agree
that you you meant the terms in your
text
uh as an insult because you didn't like
the fact that she was disapproving of
your alcohol and drug habits objection
compound sustain compound question
there was nothing no you don't have to
answer that sir sorry next question
so you're on it yes you can go up uh up
one page please
you told her
you sicken me leave me [ __ ] be
officer squarehead correct
yes
let's go to
defendants exhibit 736 please
can you scroll down please
is that the last page some more
go up then please
now mr depp i'd like to direct your
attention to the text at the bottom
we've heard
some testimony in this case the jury's
heard testimony in this case about the
events of may 21st 2016.
these texts are texts that you and amber
exchanged on may 22nd 2016.
all right you see that
yes i see that okay your honor i'd move
for the admission of uh defendants
exhibit 736.
all right any objections uh well the
identifiers need to be redacted and i
just want to clarify that the three
pages we scrolled to right through are
the only three pages sure let's take a
look at them right now
it's just those two pages oh two pages
or three pages it's just two oh if it's
just these two that that's fine okay
we'll take out the identifiers
please
all right okay um 736 and evidence as
redacted thank you
um
mr depp if you can take a look at the
text message at the bottom of the first
page
you write to
to miss her the day after
the incident on may 21st 2016 just let
me know when you have a minute and i'll
give you a call
nothing i have to say to you should
elicit anything but a sense of ease all
my love and profound apologies jay did i
read that right you did can we go to 771
please
mr depp is this a text message from you
to miss heard on may 22nd 2016.
yes that that seems to be the case yes
thank you um thank you you're on our
move for admission of this uh exhibit
with uh identifiers redacted any
objection no objection all right if you
do those redactions
all right 771 in evidence with
redactions
and on may 22nd 2016
you wrote the text that we just saw you
also texted miss heard sorry if was a
bit
please know that my hurt toward you is
over my apologies are eternal and belong
to you
solid x did i read that right
you did
can we please pull up um
uh
exhibit 587 in your honor this is an
audio recording that um it will take
about five or six minutes so it might be
take us toward the end of the day all
right 587 and is that
an audio recording a secret
is this plaintiffs or defendants
fighting it's it's defendants
um again i'm 99 sure it's it's just them
um
okay but if i i'll confirm
any objection that's fine uh can you
please just let us know which portions
you're playing of course this will be
32
10.
to 38.05
okay and
mr depp um
before
uh
before we move on at
you and miss heard saw each other in
july of 2016
um
one one final time
correct
testified to that right
you saw each other in san francisco yes
we did
i'm still not sure if that was the final
time
i believe the last time i saw her was in
her divorce attorney's office
when the agreement was signed
i'm sorry i believe uh i believe i
believe i misspoke your honor it's it
i'm sorry it's 586.
sorry it's just
same video that you're discussing just
the wrong number yes yes your honor and
and what i would propose to play is 3210
to 38.05 so we'll make it
a yes section 3210 through 38.05 all
right that's interesting
thank you and with your permission i'd
ask uh for us to play this okay jerry go
ahead thank you
actually before we start mr deb
during this meeting that you had with
her at one point you tried to cut
yourself with a knife correct
i don't recall that no okay let's play i
mean i might have
made a move
that was my fault
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really pretty
somewhere do i want to cut you yeah you
want your arm you want chests
[Music]
just don't cut your skin please do not
cook your skin please don't okay
why would i do that it's easy
don't please do not do that please do
not do that no please don't please don't
cut yourself
you don't need to cut yourself
[Music]
all right
no thank you no thank you there's sperm
on the pillows
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i would never do that to you
yeah you [ __ ] hate me come on
[Music]
won't be cut
just gonna go to court
[Music]
don't don't don't don't you tell me
please don't do that
put the knife down
just put the [ __ ] knife down
don't
don't do that
do not do that johnny
please you're gonna look at you you're
gonna hurt yourself please i want to
look at you you know
wait
stop please there's a way for the pain
to go away well it's not it's not that
it doesn't make you go away trust me
i do know it doesn't make you go away
really
did it make it go away yeah it did
please don't please don't do that okay
[Music]
there's love here
there is love here
[Music]
here
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
the knife is really dull and it would be
the worst thing in the world to use to
cut
me with
it it would be too
painful and dull and dirty to use
[Music]
right it's pretty
no no please do not do not do don't
don't don't you're gonna hurt yourself
don't
it's okay
please please don't cut yourself please
please don't
please stop please stop please
don't don't hurt yourself please
your honor i think that might if it's
okay with your honor i'm
probably going to move on to something
else
okay i assume you still have
quite a bit cross or
a bit i'm not not exactly sure all right
but more than we could do yes
okay all right that's fine all right
ladies and gentlemen it looks like we've
come to the end of our week um so i
won't be seeing you again until monday
since i won't be seeing you until monday
i just want to give you the the large
jury instruction i gave you and i'll try
to give you on each thursday evening
just to remind you since i won't see you
for three days okay
so remember it's the court's instruction
uh to you the jury that you not read
anything about this case that you not
watch anything about this case
you're not to listen to anything about
this case this applies to television
newspapers magazines the internet and
any online sites
further you're not to read watch or
listen to anything about this case on
any social media
social media networking sites such as
twitter facebook instagram
snapchat blogs or similar sites
in addition you must not communicate
with anyone about the case whether in
person over the phone by email text or
instant messaging or by any other
electronic or non-electronic means this
includes your family friends co-workers
acquaintances and strangers i also
instruct you that you cannot do any
research or make inquiries about this
case whether online or by any other
means what you learn about this case is
limited to what you learn in the four
walls of this courtroom when proceedings
are underway all right so i hope you
have a safe and quiet uh weekend and
we'll see you monday morning bright and
early okay thank you you're excused for
the weekend
all right so you can sit down with your
your attorneys mr deb you can sit down
with your attorneys go ahead you can
stick up with your attorneys
all right so tomorrow um
i will see the lit against anymore
obviously no posting on social media no
talking to the press for
from mr depp or miss her um the
attorneys i i'd like to see at nine
o'clock tomorrow if we could start at
nine please um so we can start with the
the uh deposition designation objections
um
i would uh if you could send that list
to me or to sammy
it's all yours you don't have any more
depositions we need to go through we've
done all yours
good i have 10 that i sent them last
weekend
we've sent all of our
withdrawals and objections etc i don't
have any of those well
we can do what we did last week with the
round robin the more attorneys you bring
the more round robin we can do that seem
to work okay and we'll just keep doing
it until we went to 6 30 last week i
don't know hopefully we can get done
before then but we'll stay until they
get done and and we do intend to be
sending our
that's fine we can we can discuss it
tomorrow at night and any redacted
exhibits that you're going to have for
me because now i mowed quite a bit um if
you could bring those as well whatever
you can okay and you wonder if i may
approach i just have two from yesterday
okay which always number 40 hopefully
none we're still still waiting on 40
40's on my first page so i was hoping i
could get that real quick that's okay
okay
i don't have a 492. do you have a 492.
487a
487. it's 47.
all right 487a got it
okay we'll enter those into i think you
gave this to me right
you have them
yes we have those and in your honor you
could just remind the witness that since
he's still in the sand he's not to
discuss his testimony with anyone
including right okay and again mr debson
you're still testifying you can't
discuss your testimony with anybody to
include your attorneys okay thank you
fine anything else
no you're right all right we'll see you
in the morning see you tomorrow thank
you
do
you